I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everyone. Hey!
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们是《办公室》剧组。大家好。嘿！
Oh my gosh! Why are we screaming already? We'll tell you. We are back in the studio! We are in the studio. We are vaccinated. Our team is vaccinated. Look at this.
哦，天哪！为什么我们已经在尖叫了？我们会告诉你原因的。我们回到录音室啦！我们在录音室里。我们接种过疫苗了。我们的团队都接种疫苗了。看看这个。
I can put my arms all the way out to the sides and I don't touch any clothes or any walls. I am not staring at you through my husband's t-shirts or smelling his socks. It's so exciting. Lady, I'm looking at your face in real life. It's weird. I want to touch it, but I won't. Can I get you on a Zoom? Actually, will you go in the other room?
我可以把双臂完全向两旁伸开，而不会碰到任何衣服或墙壁。我不是透过我丈夫的T恤衫盯着你，也不是在闻他的袜子。太激动了。女士，我在现实生活中看着你的脸。这感觉很奇妙。我想摸摸它，但我不会。我能通过Zoom连线你吗？事实上，你能去另一个房间吗？
Can we do this over Zoom? We are thrilled to be here. It's been over a year. Over a year? Yeah. We don't know what this is going to be, guys. We ended up doing more Office Ladies podcasts from our closet than we ever did in person. Crazy.
我们能通过Zoom做这个吗？我们很高兴能来到这里。已经一年多了。一年多？是的。伙计们，我们不知道这会是什么样。我们在衣柜里录制的《Office Ladies》播客比以往任何时候在现场录制的都要多。太疯狂了。
But we're back in person now and we don't know what's going to happen. I'll tell you a few changes right off the bat. Angela has stopped using note cards, guys, and I'm freaking out. And post-its. Sam is clapping from the engineer booth. It's a moment of growth, you guys. I have a Word document now. I put everything in.
但我们现在回到现场了，不知道会发生什么。我马上告诉你们一些变化。伙计们，安吉拉已经停止使用便签卡了，我快抓狂了。还有便签贴。山姆在工程控制室里鼓掌。伙计们，这是一个成长的时刻。我现在有一个Word文档了。我把所有东西都放进去了。
It's very adult-y. I'm not saying I'm going to stick with it. Maybe it was something I started doing because I was in my closet and I just didn't have space for all my note cards. But look at me at this big table now. I know. It's almost like you want to fill it up with note cards, don't you? A little bit.
这非常成人的样子。我不是说我会一直坚持下去。也许这只是因为我以前在衣柜里，空间不够放我所有的便签卡，所以才开始这样做的。但现在看看我坐在这张大桌子前。我知道。这感觉就像你想用便签卡把它填满一样，不是吗？有一点。
You want to fill it up. A little bit. A little bit. Well, the other big news for today is that we are kicking off season five of The Office with weight loss part one. Season flip in five. Yeah. We're here.
你想把它填满。有一点。有一点。好吧，今天的另一个重大新闻是，我们将以《减肥（上）》开启《办公室》第五季。第五季翻页了。是的。我们来了。
Here we are. Let's do it. This is season five, episode one, written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky, directed by Paul Feig. We stopped talking. We've already don't know what we're doing in here. You know what I was going to do? I was going to go, boop, boop, boop, boop, and then I was like, no, that's annoying.
我们来了。开始吧。这是第五季第一集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，保罗·费格执导。我们不说话了。我们已经不知道在这里该做什么了。你知道我要做什么吗？我本打算“嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟”，然后我想，不，这太烦人了。
So then I said nothing, and then you said nothing, and then we just stared at each other. You know why? Because we can. We've got a lot of long pauses in this podcast today. I'm going to move us into a summary. The Gang at Dunder Mifflin participates in an eight-week company-wide weight loss competition. Pam begins her three-month design program in New York City, and Andy attempts to get Angela to commit to wedding plans, but she's busy.
所以我什么也没说，然后你什么也没说，接着我们俩就大眼瞪小眼。你知道为什么吗？因为我们可以。我们今天在这个播客里有很多长时间的停顿。我要进入剧情梗概了。邓德米夫林的伙伴们参加了一个为期八周的全公司范围的减肥比赛。帕姆开始了她在纽约市为期三个月的设计项目，安迪试图让安吉拉定下婚礼计划，但她很忙。
She's having an affair with Dwight, an affair. I know. She is stressed the F out, and the minute Andy asks her about the wedding, she runs to Dwight. Yeah. I have a question about that. Why can't you guys have sex at home, like after work? Are you guys having sex at home after work, or is it only in the warehouse?
她和德怀特有私情，一段私情。我知道。她压力大得要命，安迪一问她婚礼的事，她就跑去找德怀特。是的。我有个问题想问。为什么你们不能在家里做爱，比如下班后？你们下班后会在家里做爱吗，还是只在仓库里？
That is such a good question I've never thought about. I mean, I definitely see their hookups in this episode whenever Angela is spiraling. Maybe she's happy at home with all of her cats, and maybe she doesn't let Andy come over, so she doesn't need Dwight to cope. Yeah. Or maybe they're just shagging everywhere. I don't know. Well, we'll discuss more later.
这是个我从未想过的好问题。我的意思是，每当安吉拉情绪崩溃时，我确实能在这集里看到他们偷情。也许她在家里和她所有的猫在一起很开心，也许她不让安吉拉过来，所以她不需要德怀特来应付。是的。或者他们只是到处乱搞。我不知道。好吧，我们稍后再讨论。
We'll discuss more. Guys, this was the start of our fifth season, like we said, and to make up for the shorter fourth season that got interrupted because of the writer strike, NBC ordered 28 episodes for season five. This season has the most episodes of any office season. Oh my God, I didn't know that. Yeah. That's some good office trivia, my lady.
我们稍后再讨论。伙计们，正如我们所说，这是我们第五季的开始，为了弥补因编剧罢工而中断的较短的第四季，全国广播公司（NBC）为第五季预订了28集。这一集是所有《办公室》季度中集数最多的一季。哦，天哪，我不知道。是的。这算是一些不错的办公室冷知识，女士。
Thank you. Thank you. Well, it's going to move us into fast fact number one, which is a little complicated. I'll tell you why. Okay. Back at the end of season three, we said that Rashida Jones left the show and stopped playing Karen Philippelli because she had to go do Parks and Recreation. Was she not going to do Parks and Rec then?
谢谢。谢谢。好吧，这将带我们进入第一条冷知识，这有点复杂。我来告诉你为什么。好吧。回到第三季末，我们说过拉什达·琼斯离开了剧组，不再扮演凯伦·菲利佩利，因为她得去拍《公园与游憩》。那时她不是不打算拍《公园与游憩》吗？
She wasn't, and because Parks and Recreation did not exist yet, Parks and Recreation does not exist until the middle of season five of The Office. Oh, farts. We got that wrong, Milady. We did. Why am I saying Milady? I don't know. Is Milady the new lady?
她本来不打算拍，而且因为《公园与游憩》当时还不存在，《公园与游憩》直到《办公室》第五季中段才出现。哦，屁啦。我们弄错了，女士。确实。我为什么一直说女士？我不知道。女士是新的流行词吗？
I hope not, because people right now are like, my ears are bleeding. Stop saying Milady. Wait, so Rashida, was she leaving to do a different project? No. She left because they finished the storyline of Karen, Jim and Pam. It was a storyline thing. I mean, she did go on to do more projects. She did a bunch of movies in that time.
我希望不是，因为现在人们会觉得：我的耳朵在流血。别再叫女士了。等等，拉什达，她是要去拍一个不同的项目才离开的吗？不。她离开是因为凯伦、吉姆和帕姆的故事线结束了。这是一个关于故事线的问题。我的意思是，她后来确实去做了更多的项目。那段时间她拍了一堆电影。
But no, it was a storyline thing. Similarly, I'll have you know that we wondered during Branch Wars if the photo of Hillary Clinton in her office was a nod to Leslie Knoop loving Hillary Clinton. We thought that it was. It wasn't because, again, there was no Leslie Knoop. There was no Parks and Rec yet. We were determined to pull up Parks and Rec by a few years. Well, I love Parks and Rec, so.
但不是，这是一个故事线的问题。同样，我想让你们知道，我们在《分部之战》中想过，她办公室里希拉里·克林顿的照片是不是在向莱斯利·克诺普喜爱希拉里·克林顿致敬。我们以为是的。其实不是，因为同样地，当时还没有莱斯利·克诺普。当时还没有《公园与游憩》。我们硬生生地把《公园与游憩》的时间提前了好几年。好吧，我很喜欢《公园与游憩》，所以。
I know. Okay. Well, there you go. We got that wrong. So this is important for two reasons. One, we need to know the timeline of Parks and Rec. Clearly. And number two, Greg Daniels, who created the American version of The Office, he created
我知道。好吧，就这样吧。我们弄错了。所以这有两点很重要。第一，我们需要知道《公园与游憩》的时间线。很显然。第二，创作了美国版《办公室》的格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他创作了
Parks and Rec, along with one of our writers, Mike Shore. So midway through this season five, we're going to lose both Greg and Mike because they're going to be working on Parks and Rec. And that is why Jen Solada and Paulie Bernstein take over as the showrunners for season five. All right. There you go. Now, Mike sure moved to Parks and Rec full time. Greg was doing both shows.
《公园与游憩》，还有我们的编剧之一迈克·舒尔。所以在第五季中段，我们将失去格雷格和迈克，因为他们要去制作《公园与游憩》。这就是为什么珍·索拉达和保利·伯恩斯坦接任第五季剧集主管的原因。好了。就是这样。现在，迈克·舒尔全职转到了《公园与游憩》。格雷格两边兼顾。
Greg did a little bit of Parks and Rec. He did a little office. He bounced back and forth. He did. Yes. He did us to get that timeline correct. Yes. All right.
格雷格做了一点《公园与游憩》。他也做了一点《办公室》。他两头跑。他确实做了。是的。他为了帮我们理清那个时间线而努力。是的。好吧。
Fast fact number two, writer of this episode, Gene Stupnitsky, said that the idea for a weight loss episode had been on the writer's wall for a really long time, but they couldn't figure out how to do it in one day because remember, they had that rule where they tried to have plot lines that only cover one work day. Right. When NBC asked for the premiere of season five to be an hour long, Greg Daniels had the idea that we could do the weight loss episode as a sort of summer retrospective. Right.
第二条冷知识，本集编剧吉恩·斯图普尼茨基说，减肥剧集的想法在编剧墙上挂了很长时间，但他们一直想不出如何在一天内拍完，因为大家还记得，他们有一条规定，就是尽量让剧情只涵盖一个工作日。对。当NBC要求第五季首播集为一个小时长时，格雷格·丹尼尔斯提出了一个想法，我们可以把减肥这一集当作某种夏季回顾来做。对。
Because we never see the characters over the summer. Yeah. Gene said this was a really cool opportunity to see the characters over their summertime and that they almost called this episode summer. You might notice also for this episode, there is no cold open. It just starts with the opening credits. Gene said that there was a cold open in the script. It was written that way, but they actually just folded it in to the plot and he said
因为我们从未在夏天看到过这些角色。是的。吉恩说，这是一个非常酷的机会，可以看到夏天时的角色们，他们差点把这一集命名为“夏天”。你们可能还会注意到，这一集没有冷开场。它直接从片头字幕开始。吉恩说剧本里其实有一个冷开场。剧本是那样写的，但他们实际上把它融入到了剧情中，而且他说
that the pacing of this episode is a little quicker than previous seasons. This is going to become kind of our new pacing moving forward and that this was a change they made so they could fit in more jokes and more supporting character storylines. I mean, I definitely noticed. I felt like it clipped along. Yes. In fact, number three, this episode has an all crew commentary Angela, take it away. It does.
这一集的节奏比前几季要快一些。这在某种程度上将成为我们以后前进的新节奏，这是一个他们做出的改变，以便能够塞进更多的笑话和更多的配角剧情线。我的意思是，我确实注意到了。我觉得它节奏很明快。是的。事实上，第三条冷知识，这一集有全体剧组成员的评论音轨，安吉拉，你来介绍一下。有的。
You guys, when I started listening to this DVD commentary and realized it was all crew, I called Jenna right away. It was one of the best DVD commentaries I've listened to up until now. It's so good. And you've listened to all of them. I have. And I want to share with you guys who is on this DVD commentary for weight loss. Okay.
伙计们，当我开始听这个DVD评论音轨并意识到这是全体剧组成员时，我立刻给珍娜打了电话。这是我迄今为止听过的最好的DVD评论之一。太棒了。而且你把所有的都听过了。我听过。我想和大家分享一下，谁参与了这集《减肥》的DVD评论。好吧。
It's phenomenal. So much information. At the beginning of the DVD commentary, everyone in the crew went around, said their names and their job title for this episode. Okay. Randy Cordray, our brand new line producer, Michael Gallenberg, our production designer, Brian Whittle, our boom operator, Nick Carbone, our sound utility, Ben Patrick, our production sound mixer, Alicia Raycraft, our new costume designer, Kelly Cantley, our first assistant
太精彩了。有太多的信息了。在DVD评论的开始，剧组的每个人都轮流说出了他们的名字以及他们在这集中的职位。好的。兰迪·科德雷，我们的全新制片经理，迈克尔·加伦贝格，我们的制作设计师，布赖恩·惠特尔，我们的挑杆录音师，尼克·卡尔波尼，我们的声音助理，本·帕特里克，我们的制作录音师，艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫特，我们的新服装设计师，凯利·坎特利，我们的第一助理
director, and Jake Oust, our post producer. Oh my gosh. What was it like to hear all of their voices again? It was so wonderful. And you know, Kelly Cantley, I loved her so much. And Jenna, we still are on each other's Christmas card list. We send each other Christmas cards every year and I just adore her. And I texted her.
导演，以及杰克·奥斯特，我们的后期制片人。哦，天哪。再次听到他们所有人的声音是什么感觉？太美妙了。而且你知道，凯利·坎特利，我太喜欢她了。而且珍娜，我们依然在彼此的圣诞贺卡名单上。我们每年都互相寄圣诞贺卡，我简直爱死她了。我给她发了短信。
I said, Kelly, I can't tell you how wonderful it is. I just spent an hour with you, like listening to your voice. I miss you so much. And she was like, Angie, I miss you too. And I get her Christmas cards too from her and her husband, Kevin, and their two dogs. I look forward to them every year. There is so much awesome information about the making of Weight Loss 1 and 2. First thing I want to share with you guys that this was Randy and Alicia's first episode
我说，凯利，我无法告诉你这有多美妙。我刚刚和你们一起度过了一个小时，就像在听你的声音一样。我太想你了。她说，安吉拉，我也想你。我也收到她和她丈夫凯文以及他们的两只狗寄给我的圣诞贺卡。我每年都盼着它们。关于制作《减肥（上）和（下）》，有太多棒极了的信息了。首先我想和大家分享的是，这是兰迪和艾莉西亚在《办公室》里参与制作的第一集
that they ever worked on on The Office and what an enormous, huge way to start their time on the show. So normally one episode, as Jenna said, is one day, they had to take our show over the course of eight weeks in one episode. It was a continuity nightmare. For Alicia, wardrobe had eight changes. And Jenna, you and I love tracking things. Well, guess who else loves tracking things?
，以如此庞大、盛大的方式开始他们在剧组的时光。所以通常一集，正如珍娜所说，是一天，而他们必须把我们剧中的八周时间压缩在一集里。这是一场连戏的噩梦。对艾莉西亚来说，服装有八次换装。珍娜，你和我都喜欢追踪各种细节。好吧，猜猜还有谁也喜欢追踪细节？
Alicia. Kelly Cantley. Oh boy. Kelly Cantley, she listed off all of the things that they would have to track over Weight Loss 1 and 2. I loved it so much. I wrote it down and I began to track it as well. Number one, eight wardrobe changes.
艾莉西亚。凯利·坎特利。哦，天哪。凯利·坎特利，她列出了他们必须在《减肥（上）和（下）》中追踪的所有事情。我太喜欢了。我把它写了下来，我也开始追踪了。第一，八套服装更迭。
Number two, eight set dressings of the main office bullpen. Number three, was it raining or not raining outside the windows depending on the scene? Number four, they had three different goatee beards on Michael, Ryan and Dwight. Number five, Meredith's sunburn face, we'll get to that. Number six, the dry erase board with everyone's weight loss stats. Number seven, the fruit flies and number eight, the rotting of fruit. Wow. That's what they were keeping track of.
第二，主办公室开敞式办公区的八种布景。第三，根据场景不同，窗外是在下雨还是没下雨。第四，迈克尔、瑞安和德怀特有三种不同的山羊胡造型。第五，梅雷迪思晒伤的脸，我们一会儿会聊到。第六，写着每个人减肥数据的干擦白板。第七，果蝇，以及第八，水果的腐烂。哇。这就是他们一直在追踪的东西。
So many things. And then lastly, this episode was a huge challenge for the editing department. Do you remember in Goodbye Toby how I had the script, I had the shooting draft and I kept telling you how the scenes were all rearranged differently for the episode that actually aired? Yeah. I heard in the commentary that Greg and the writers were very used to being able to just move scenes around and kind of change how the episode would take shape. And they could not do that in this episode because it's week to week and everything
有这么多的事情。然后最后，这一集对剪辑部门来说是一个巨大的挑战。你们还记得在《告别托比》中，我有剧本，我有拍摄初稿，我一直告诉你们场景是如何为实际播出的那一集重新排列组合的吗？是的。我在评论音轨中听说，格雷格和编剧们非常习惯于直接移动场景，有点像改变一集成型的方式。但他们在这集里做不到这一点，因为它是周复一周的，一切都
progresses week to week within one episode and you can't move around that story. No. And our clothes are changing, right? Yes. Like you'd notice, but there is, I saw a little flub. Yes. And they have to bring that up and they also address, and I'll bring this up when it happens, a character that they had to keep digitally changing their shirt.
在一集之内周复一周地推进，你不能随意移动那个故事。没有。而且我们的衣服在变，对吧？是的。就像你会注意到的，但是有一个，我看到了一个小失误。是的。他们不得不提出来，他们还讨论了一个角色，他们必须在数字上不断改变他们的衬衫，我会在事情发生时提到这一点。
What? Yes. I'll share when we get to the moment. Angela, I think you need to do fast facts more often because that is possibly one of my favorite fast facts we've ever done. I'm giving you fast fact number three from now on. Oh, I bet you are. Thanks.
什么？是的。等我们到那个时刻时我再分享。安吉拉，我觉得你需要更经常地做冷知识环节，因为这可能是我做过的最喜欢的冷知识之一。从现在开始，我把冷知识第三条交给你了。哦，我敢打赌你会的。谢谢。
I know. You guys, fast facts are really hard. Regina created fast facts for herself and then was like, Angela, these dang fast facts. I wish every week the crew did the DVD commentary is what I wish because it's the best commentary. It was the most insightful, interesting, the best background trivia. Fast fact three was easy because of our crew's commentary. I cannot wait to watch that payoff as we break down this episode. Let's take a break.
我知道。伙计们，冷知识真的很难。雷吉娜为自己创作了冷知识，然后说，安吉拉，这些该死的冷知识。我希望每周剧组都能做DVD评论音轨，这是我最大的愿望，因为这是最好的评论。这是最具洞察力、最有趣、最好的背景冷知识。由于我们剧组的评论，冷知识第三条变得很简单。我等不及要在我们剖析这一集时看到这个回报了。我们休息一下吧。
Shocker, I need to go to the bathroom. You know, we've had a big morning. It was a reunion. We both drank lots of beverages. All right, we're going to go to the restroom. We'll be right back. All right, well, we are back. Everyone is in the conference room.
令人震惊的是，我要去上厕所。你知道，我们今天早上经历了一场大事。这是一场重聚。我们俩都喝了好多饮料。好吧，我们要去洗手间了。马上回来。好吧，我们回来了。大家都在会议室里。
They are having a feast. I mean, there is a buffet of food happening here. Yeah. Michael tells everyone they better eat up because it's their last meal. They're going to start this weight loss competition, but first they're trying to bulk up. So that when they lose weight, the number is big. There's a big difference. Yes.
他们在开饕餮盛宴。我的意思是，这里简直有一个自助餐在举行。是的。迈克尔告诉大家最好吃个够，因为这是他们的最后一餐。他们要开始这个减肥比赛了，但首先他们要增肥。这样当他们减肥时，数字才会很大。这里面有很大的区别。是的。
Exactly. Dwight has also told people they can't even use the bathroom. You're going to have to hold it. They want maximum poundage on the scale. And the stakes are high because Michael explains that this is a corporate weight loss challenge and the branch that loses the most weight wins three whole extra vacation days. Everyone's excited. Yeah.
没错。德怀特还告诉大家甚至不准去上厕所。你们得憋着。他们想要秤上的最大磅数。而且赌注很高，因为迈克尔解释说这是一场公司层面的减肥挑战赛，减肥最多的分部将赢得整整三天额外的假期。大家都兴奋极了。是的。
I paused and I went frame by frame and I made a list of all the food I could see. I love this. This is reminding me a little bit of my pizza biafrito moment. Is it going to be 10 minutes? No, there's not that much food. Okay. Let's hear it. All right.
我暂停了视频，逐帧查看，列出了我能看到的所有食物。我喜欢这个。这让我想起了我吃炸披萨的那个时刻。会持续10分钟吗？不，没有那么多食物。好吧。让我们听听。好吧。
There is a chocolate fondue fountain. There is a cheese fondue fountain. There are marshmallows, fried chicken, ribs, maybe some waffles, cornbread muffins, donuts, lots of soda, mac and cheese, dumplings. I swear someone has mashed potatoes and gravy on their plate. And then Jim has some strawberries on his plate, probably for the chocolate fountain, but I was surprised to spot a bit of healthy food. Not surprised to see it on John Krasinski's plate, however.
有一个巧克力火锅喷泉。有一个奶酪火锅喷泉。有棉花糖、炸鸡、排骨、可能还有华夫饼、玉米面包松饼、甜甜圈、很多苏打水、通心粉奶酪、饺子。我发誓有人盘子里有土豆泥和肉汁。然后吉姆盘子里有一些草莓，可能是为了沾巧克力喷泉，但我很惊讶地发现了一点健康食物。不过，在约翰·卡拉辛斯基的盘子里看到这个并不让人意外。
He was such a healthy eater. He was. Jenna, do you know what I remember about this scene? What? How funky that cheese got. Yeah. It got real smelly. Yeah.
他一直是个很健康的食客。他确实是。珍娜，你知道我对这一场戏有什么记忆吗？什么？那奶酪变得多古怪。是的。它变得真的很臭。是的。
Kelly shares on the DVD that they could only keep that cheese melted for three hours. It would start to coagulate from whatever it got so gross. I mean, that really makes me think twice about any cheese fondue fountain. The fountain food. I might be done with fountain food. When I was in college, I had a boyfriend and we read that there was this protein shake company that was going to give a $10,000 prize to whoever lost the most weight and gained the most muscle by using their protein shake.
凯利在DVD上分享说，他们只能让那奶酪融化三个小时。无论它沾到什么上面，它都会开始凝固，变得超级恶心。我的意思是，这真的让我对任何奶酪火锅喷泉三思而后行。喷泉食物。我可能对喷泉食物免疫了。我在上大学时，有个男朋友，我们读到有一家蛋白粉公司要给使用他们的蛋白粉减肥最多、肌肉增最多的人提供10,000美元的奖金。
Right. So the idea is to get healthy, lose weight, and here's your incentive as a bunch of money or something. Yeah. So we entered. You and your boyfriend? Yeah. You did the shake challenge?
对。所以这个想法是变得健康、减肥，这里的激励是一大笔钱之类的东西。是的。所以我们参加了。你和你的男友？对。你们做了蛋白粉挑战？
We did. Yeah. We did the same thing. We're like, in the week before we ate a bunch of food, I probably gained about five pounds in one week. Yeah. Because we just like ate pizza and burgers because we were like, this is great. I mean, we'll start out with more weight and then we'll lose it all and more and we'll
我们做了。是的。我们做了同样的事情。我们想，在比赛前的一周里，我们吃了一堆食物，我可能在一周内胖了大约五磅。是的。因为我们只是吃披萨和汉堡，因为我们觉得，这太棒了。我的意思是，我们从更重的体重开始，然后我们会把它全减掉，甚至减掉更多，然后我们就会
win $10,000. Yeah. I mean, we took pictures of ourselves. I still have it. Oh, no. I mean, somewhere I have it. I know because I was cleaning out some old photo albums and I found it and it jogged this memory.
赢得10,000美元。是的。我的意思是，我们拍了自己的照片。我还留着。哦，不。我的意思是，在某个地方我留着它。我知道，因为我在清理一些旧相册时找到了它，这段记忆就被唤醒了。
You had to prove the day of the weight loss start. Yeah. So you had to hold up that day's newspaper. I mean, like a hostage photo. Oh, my God. So I've got this picture of myself. This was before you could Instagram. Now you can Instagram and it's a timestamp, but back then you had to hold up like a newspaper.
你必须证明减肥开始的那天。是的。所以你必须举起那一天的报纸。我的意思是，就像一张人质照片。哦，天哪。所以我有一张自己的照片。这是在Instagram出现之前。现在你可以在Instagram上发照片，它有时间戳，但在那个时候你必须举起一张报纸。
Yeah. And take it with a regular old camera. I'm in like a sports bra and some like sports shorts and I'm holding up a newspaper and I will tell you what, not only did we not win, I did not lose any of the weight. That you gained car bloating. That's right. After the eight weeks, I mean, we gave up so quickly. We were all in for the first week of the fitness challenge and then all that happened was from
是的。用一台老式普通的相机拍。我穿着一件运动内衣和一些运动短裤，我举着报纸，我得告诉你，我们不仅没赢，我连一磅肉都没减掉。你长胖长出来的那些。没错。八周之后，我的意思是，我们放弃得太快了。我们在健身挑战的第一周全力以赴，然后发生的一切就是
all of this is that I gained five pounds and then I held up a newspaper the end. So that memory came flooding back as I was watching us in this conference room scene. So Stanley, Meredith and Creed have plans for their leftovers. You know, Stanley really wants to take some of these dumplings home, but Dwight is like, no, no, you cannot take any of this food home. We're eating healthy now. And he starts spraying what looks like an insect repellent all over all of the food. We had a fan question from Chelsea B, Alice R, and Henry F. What was in the bottle that
这一切让我胖了五磅，然后我举着报纸，结束。所以当我看着我们在会议室里的这场戏时，这段记忆一下子涌了上来。所以斯坦利、梅雷迪思和克里德对他们的剩菜有了计划。你知道，斯坦利真的很想把这些饺子带回家一些，但德怀特说，不，不，你们不能把任何这些食物带回家。我们现在要吃得健康。然后他开始在所有的食物上喷洒看起来像杀虫剂的东西。我们收到了来自切尔西·B、爱丽丝·R和亨利·F的粉丝提问。德怀特在食物上喷的瓶子里装的是什么？
Dwight is spraying on the food? Well, guess who knows? You? Me. Thanks to our crew. It was not real bug spray, of course. This was a prop bottle that Phil Shea had designed. He had this made and it was full of aerosol water.
好吧，猜猜谁知道？你？我。多亏了我们的剧组。当然不是真的杀虫剂。这是一个菲尔·谢伊设计并制作的道具瓶。他让人做了这个，里面装满了气溶胶水。
Oh. So he was just spraying water. You know, I assumed that's what it was, but it didn't look like water. I mean, it looks so real. I thought it looked real and I thought everyone's reactions were really good. Great acting, folks. You sold it. Well, now the gang is going to go down to the warehouse.
哦。所以他只是在喷水。你知道，我猜是那样的，但它看起来不像水。我的意思是，它看起来太真实了。我觉得它看起来很真实，而且我觉得大家的反应都很好。演技真棒，各位。你们演得很真。好吧，现在伙伴们要下到仓库去了。
They're going to weigh in. Yes. And Jenna, at one minute, five seconds, there is a great shot of the big scale that we're all going to get weighed on and I have a prop breakdown. Give it to me. Okay. That scale was custom made by Rice Lake Wing Systems. They made it specific to our request and they were able to program the little computer
他们要过磅了。是的。而且珍娜，在一分五秒的时候，有一个很好的镜头，拍的是我们所有人都要上去过磅的大秤，我有一个道具细节拆解。快告诉我。好的。那个秤是由莱斯利湖称重系统公司定制的。他们根据我们的要求专门制造了它，并且他们能够
screen with whatever the writers wanted them to put on it, right? It was like part of the joke. Our weight, that was all like a writer's joke. My mind is being blown right now that that was not a real scale. No. The scale didn't exist. It was made just for us. And Rice Lake Wing System didn't ask for any credit or any company plug.
用编剧们希望他们放在上面的任何内容来对那个小电脑屏幕进行编程，对吧？这就像是个笑话的一部分。我们的体重，那全都是编剧的笑话。我现在简直惊呆了，那不是一个真正的秤。没有。那个秤根本不存在。它是专门为我们制作的。而且莱斯利湖称重系统公司没有要求任何鸣谢或公司植入。
They were huge fans of the show and they did come to set the day we filmed this. And everyone on our crew said they were so nice. And after this episode aired, that scale stayed in the warehouse as part of the warehouse set. That I remember. Mm-hmm. Now, during this weigh-in, Angela, what's up with Meredith's face? Did you notice?
他们是这部剧的超级粉丝，而且他们确实在我们拍摄这一天的来到片场。我们剧组的每个人都说他们太好了。而且在这集播出后，那个秤作为仓库布景的一部分留在了仓库里。这个我记得。嗯-哼。现在，在这个过磅环节，安吉拉，梅雷迪思的脸怎么了？你注意到了吗？
Her face is all red. We got a lot of mail about it. They want to know what's going on. Was there a storyline that was cut or something? Oh, yes. I want you guys to know I took a photo of Kate's face as Meredith looking like that. And I texted it to Kate last night and I said, Kate, you know what? You should win Team Player Award for the run of the office because her character was always
她的脸全红了。我们收到了很多关于这事的邮件。他们想知道发生了什么。是不是有一条剧情线被删了或者别的什么？哦，是的。我想让大家知道，我拍了一张凯特作为梅雷迪思顶着那张脸的照片。昨晚我把照片发给了凯特，我说，凯特，你知道吗？在《办公室》整整四季的播出期间，你应该赢得最佳团队合作奖，因为她的角色总是
getting into some kind of mishap, which resulted in Kate being in the hair and makeup trailer forever, right? Yeah. Yeah. And that was the storyline, and it's shared in the deleted scenes. Meredith gets severely sunburned. And here is her explanation. Sam, can you play the clip?
陷入各种各样的倒霉事，这导致凯特不得不在化妆车里待上无休止的时间，对吧？是的。是的。这就是那条剧情线，它在被删减的片段中分享了。梅雷迪思严重晒伤了。这是她的解释。山姆，你能播放一下这个片段吗？
These guys took me on a fishing boat. I don't think I caught anything. Hello, hello, hey. Your face is almost back to normal. One more kid calls me Hellboy. I swear to God. Oh, you wish. Hellboy's a hero.
这帮人把我带上一艘渔船。我觉得我什么都没钓到。你好，你好，嘿。你的脸几乎快恢复正常了。还有一个小孩叫我地狱男爵。我向上帝发誓。哦，你想得美。地狱男爵是个英雄。
Oh, wow. Yeah. They took me on a boat, got super, super sunburned. And this was something they had to watch in continuity of which stage of the sunburn was her face at. Then the whole storyline got deleted, but they couldn't take out Kate's face. You know what I mean? Yeah.
哦，哇。是的。他们把我带上一艘船上，晒得超级超级严重。这是他们必须关注的连戏问题，即她的脸处于晒伤的哪个阶段。然后整条剧情线都被删了，但他们无法去掉凯特的脸。你知道我的意思吗？是的。
Yeah. So they just had to leave it in. And Kate said the day after the show aired, Steve came up to her on set and was like, you know what, Kate? I still thought it was funny. You know, I kind of love that Meredith has this mystery about her, that she has this whole other life we don't even need to explain. And Kate said it made her feel so good that Steve was so thoughtful to come over and say
是的。所以他们只能把它留在片中。凯特说节目播出后的第二天，史蒂夫在片场走到她面前说，你知道吗，凯特？我还是觉得这挺搞笑的。你知道，我有点喜欢梅雷迪思身上这种神秘感，她有着我们甚至不需要解释的另一面生活。凯特说，史蒂夫能那么贴心地走过来这么说，让她感觉太棒了
that. Yeah. That was hard when you had a storyline and then you'd watch the episode. They wouldn't warn you a lot of the times. You'd just watch the episode and it was gone. Yeah. And you know, with supporting cast, we were often, you know, in the BRC story and those really got moved around a lot.
。是的。当你有了一条剧情线，然后你看播出的那一集时，那种感觉真难受。他们很多时候不会事先警告你。你只是看那一集，然后它就没了。是的。而且你知道，作为配角，我们经常在B组或C组故事里，那些剧情真的被挪动了很多次。
And trimmed and edited and it did happen. But Kate, man, such a good sport. Wow. So guys, also in this scene, Michael throws Pam off the scale because she's going to go away to art school. So he doesn't want her extra poundage. Now they've already weighed in and then Pam gets off the scale and a new weight is displayed. So embarrassing.
并且被删减和编辑，这确实发生了。但凯特，天哪，真是个拿得起放得下的人。哇。所以伙计们，也在这场戏中，迈克尔把帕姆从秤上赶了下去，因为她要去艺术学校了。所以他不想算上她多出来的体重。现在他们已经过完磅了，然后帕姆从秤上下来，显示出了一个新的体重。太尴尬了。
Everyone is clocking this number change. Yeah. We got some fan mail from Kim See who said, during the group weigh in, it becomes clear that Pam weighs 126 pounds. Jenna, did the writers consult you about your actual weight when they added this fact? Or did they just guess how much they thought you might weigh? And were you comfortable with sharing this speculation about your weight? Well, I'll tell you guys, actually in the script, the original table draft, Pam weighed
每个人都在注意到这个体重的变化。是的。我们收到了来自金·西的粉丝邮件，她说，在集体过磅期间，很明显帕姆重126磅。珍娜，当编剧们加入这个事实时，他们有向你咨询你的实际体重吗？还是他们只是猜测他们认为你可能有多重？你对分享这种关于你体重的猜测感到自在吗？嗯，我告诉大家，其实在剧本里，最初的围读草案中，帕姆重
145 pounds. And I said, you guys, this is, I feel like a weird thing for me to split hairs about. But I don't weigh 145 pounds. It's not accurate. Why don't you just put my real weight, which at the time was 126 pounds. I don't weigh 126 pounds anymore. But at the time that was my weight. And so they changed it.
145磅。我说，伙计们，我觉得在这上面纠结有点奇怪。但我并不重145磅。这不准确。你们为什么不直接写我真实的体重，当时是126磅。我现在不重126磅了。但那时那是我的体重。所以他们就改了。
Yeah. But yeah, when they speculated about my weight, they put me at 145 and I just, I don't know, I just corrected it. I thought it should be correct. I have no problem with that. Well, Jenna, that scene made me laugh just because your performance, your reaction. You watch everyone doing the math and you're just standing there. And it was very funny the way you, you played that moment.
是的。但是，当他们猜测我的体重时，他们把我写成了145磅，然后我，我不知道，我只是纠正了它。我觉得它应该准确。我对这一点没有意见。好吧，珍娜，那场戏让我发笑，仅仅因为你的表演，你的反应。你看着每个人都在做数学计算，而你只是站在那里。你处理那个时刻的方式非常有趣。
Now it's week two of their weight loss contest. Oscar and Andy arrived, they're going to hold the elevator for Stanley. And Stanley says he forgot something and then he takes the stairs without them knowing. And he has a great talking head where he shares that he's been losing weight on his own. And he just noticed some of your speed and fire that he's lost a little bit of his pick up and go. And he's doing this for himself. Yes.
现在是他们减肥比赛的第二周。奥斯卡和安迪到了，他们要为斯坦利按住电梯。而斯坦利说他忘了一些东西，然后他们在不知情的情况下走楼梯走了。他有一个很棒的单人访谈，在其中他分享说他一直在靠自己的力量减肥。他只是注意到自己失去了一些速度和活力，他失去了一些雷厉风行的干劲。而他这是在为自己做这件事。是的。
And in this talking head, he shows an old photo of himself. Well, we got some mail about that. People wanted to know, what is this picture? Is this from Leslie David Baker's real life? Yes. Is this young Leslie in this photo? It is young Leslie in the photo. Oh my gosh.
在这个单人访谈中，他展示了一张自己年轻时的照片。好吧，我们收到了一些关于这的邮件。人们想知道，这张照片是什么？这是来自莱斯利·大卫·贝克的现实生活吗？是的。这张照片里是年轻的莱斯利吗？照片里确实是年轻的莱斯利。哦，天哪。
I texted Leslie and he gave me all the info. Oh, let's hear it. It's a Photoshop picture. He does not know any of the other people in the picture. Got it. They photoshopped him into it using one of his old prom photos. Oh Leslie, I love that. Yeah.
我给莱斯利发了短信，他给了我所有的信息。哦，让我们听听。这是一张经过P图的照片。他不认识照片里的任何其他人。明白了。他们利用他的一张旧毕业舞会照片把他P进去了。哦，莱斯利，我太喜欢这个了。是的。
Well, they're really taking this whole get healthy fitness thing seriously. Holly is running a yoga class in the conference room. I only saw three people in attendance. Creed, Kelly and Michael. I didn't see anyone else. Oh, yeah. And then Michael is so excited. He runs up to Jim as Jim is going into the bathroom and is like, did you see Holly's
好吧，他们真的很严肃地对待这个变健康的健身事情。霍莉正在会议室里上一节瑜伽课。我只看到三个人出席。克里德、凯利和迈克尔。我没看到其他人。哦，是的。然后迈克尔兴奋极了。当吉姆走进洗手间时，他跑向吉姆说，你看到霍莉的
butt? And Jim's like, no. You know why? Because we don't do that. Friends don't talk about other friends' butts, right? And Jim is really trying to get Michael to have a little growth, right? And he's like, what have you learned about her? And Michael says, I learned that she broke her left leg twice in one year.
屁股了吗？吉姆说，没有。你知道为什么吗？因为我们不那样做。朋友不会谈论其他朋友的屁股，对吧？吉姆真的在试图让迈克尔有一点成长，对吧？他说，你对她有什么了解？迈克尔说，我了解到她在一年内左腿骨折了两次。
I learned that she's allergic to sesame seeds. I learned that she has read Lonesome Dove three times and that her butt refuses to quit, you know? And Jim's like, I give up. Little sidebar moment for you. What's that? Lonesome Dove was written by Larry McMurtry, who is from my hometown of Archer City, Texas. Yes.
我了解到她对芝麻过敏。我了解到她读过三遍《寂鸽之乡》，而且她的屁股死活不肯罢休，你知道吗？吉姆说，我放弃了。给你们一个小插曲时刻。什么？《寂鸽之乡》是拉里·麦克默特里写的，他来自我的家乡德克萨斯州阿彻市。是的。
And I knew Larry and I know his family and Larry was this amazing prolific writer. I got so excited just to see one of his pieces of work mentioned on the office knowing that I grew up going to his bookstore. That is so cool. Love it. I just got to know, there's only like 1,800 people in Archer City. So everybody knows everybody. We got some fan mail from Brittany.
我认识拉里，我也认识他的家人，拉里是一位了不起的多产作家。一想到我从小去他的书店，能在《办公室》里看到他的作品之一被提及，我就兴奋得不得了。太酷了。我太喜欢了。我必须知道，阿彻市只有大约1,800人。所以每个人都认识每个人。我们收到了来自布兰妮的粉丝邮件。
Uh-huh. She did her own little mini deep dive on, on sesame seed allergies. Oh. Yeah. She did a deep dive? She did. She said that she would like us to know that sesame seed allergies are actually the ninth most common type of food allergy.
嗯-哼。她对芝麻过敏做了一次属于她自己的迷你深度挖掘。哦。是的。她做了一次深度挖掘？她做了。她说她希望我们知道，芝麻过敏其实是第九大最常见的食物过敏类型。
I did not know that. Do you have any allergies? I do. I got to sweet potatoes. Crazy. Yeah. I found that out late in life because my mom would only make sweet potatoes at Thanksgiving and I'm sorry mom, but they always looked really gross to me.
我不知道这一点。你有什么过敏吗？我有。我对红薯过敏。太疯狂了。是的。我在生活较晚的时候才发现这一点，因为我妈妈只在感恩节做红薯，对不起妈妈，但我总是觉得它们看起来真的很恶心。
So I just never even ate them. I don't know if I had some sort of like visceral kind of instinct that I shouldn't eat them. Like your body knew. Yeah. But I never ate them. And then my first Thanksgiving in Los Angeles, I couldn't go home, I couldn't afford it. So me and my friends, we had our own Thanksgiving and someone brought some sweet potatoes that looked effing amazing.
所以我从来不吃它们。我不知道我当时是不是有什么本能直觉觉得我不应该吃它们。就像你的身体知道一样。是的。但我从来没吃过。然后我在洛杉矶过的第一个感恩节，我不能回家，我负担不起。所以我和我的朋友们过了我们自己的感恩节，有人带来了一些看起来他妈的太棒了的红薯。
So I had some, the next day I got super sick. I wrote it off. I had taken some of those sweet potatoes home as a leftover. I ate them again, got super sick again. That's when the doctor was like, I think you should stop eating sweet potatoes. I got an allergy test and I am allergic to sweet potatoes. My daughter has a mild allergy to dairy, but you can really tell like if she's had, you know, ice cream and stuff, she'll get really stuffy.
所以我吃了一些，第二天我病得厉害。我没当回事。我把那些红薯作为剩菜打包带回家了一些。我又吃了一次，又病得厉害。那时医生说，我想你以后应该别吃红薯了。我做了一个过敏测试，我对红薯过敏。我女儿对乳制品有轻微过敏，但你真的能看出，如果她吃了，你知道的，冰淇淋之类的东西，她就会鼻塞得很厉害。
Oh, yeah. Yeah. A lot of people have like a lactose intolerance that causes like some kind of like diarrhea. Well, this is our spin-off podcast. It's called, what food studio? Body fluids and other stories. I mean, since we're on the subject of milk and stuff, I just want to say, guys, don't give milk to cats.
哦，是的。是的。很多人有乳糖不耐症，会导致某种腹泻。好吧，这是我们的衍生播客。它叫，什么食物工作室？体液和其他故事。我的意思是，既然我们谈论牛奶之类的话题，我只想说，伙计们，不要给猫喂牛奶。
Oh, yeah. It makes them sick. Yeah. It's like a thing that's been passed down in these cartoons forever. You give cats a dish of milk. They are allergic to the dairy and milk. Don't give it to them. Can I add to your milk with cats thing?
哦，是的。这会让它们生病。是的。这就像是这些动画片里代代相传的事情。你给猫一碟牛奶。它们对乳制品和牛奶过敏。不要喂它们。我能补充一下你关于猫和牛奶的观点吗？
Oh, yeah. Don't give bread to ducks. Oh, bread to ducks. You know what you can give them, what, peas and bird seed. Okay. More food talk for you. Three minutes, 49 seconds. Dwight is replacing the junk food in the vending machine with fruit.
哦，是的。不要给鸭子喂面包。哦，给鸭子喂面包。你知道你可以喂它们什么吗，豌豆和鸟食。好的。给你们更多关于食物的谈话。三分49秒。德怀特正在用水果替换自动售货机里的垃圾食品。
Now, Kelly Cantley said, this scene, which I timed, it's seven seconds, took them one hour to shoot. Because of the like banging the fruit in with the hammer. Just all of it, ripping everything out, resetting it, putting the fruit in. It took them an hour to do a seven second scene. Coming up is a really awkward scene in so many ways. So many. The instructor is going to offer to set Holly up with his yoga instructor.
现在，凯利·坎特利说，这个场景，我计时了，只有七秒钟，他们花了一个小时才拍完。因为要用锤子把水果砸进去。所有这些，把一切都扯出来，重置，把水果放进去。他们花了一个小时来拍一个七秒钟的场景。接下来是一个在很多方面都很尴尬的场景。非常尴尬。教练要主动提出把霍莉介绍给他的瑜伽教练。
I feel like that was awkward number one. I mean, it's jumping in real quick being matchmaker. Yeah. I always feel like you wait for someone to ask you to set them up because there are so many assumptions you're making about their life and their preferences when you offer to set them up. Right? Yeah.
我觉得那是第一号尴尬。我的意思是，这就像当媒人一样立刻插手。是的。我总觉得你会等别人主动要求你帮他们介绍，因为当你主动提出介绍时，你对他们的生活和偏好做了太多的假设。对吧？是的。
So, like, how long has he known her? Have they hung out? Like, what does he know about Holly, right? Right. This takes us to front reception and Jim is making sure Pam is all packed for New York. He's holding a box of her items she's going to take with her. Did you notice at four minutes, 47 seconds, what is in the box that is so important? It's got to travel to New York City with Pam.
所以，比如，他认识她多久了？他们一起出去玩过吗？比如，他对霍莉了解多少，吧？对。这把我们带到了前台接待处，吉姆正在确保帕姆为去纽约做好了所有打包准备。他拿着一盒她要带走的物品。你有没有注意到在四分钟47秒时，箱子里有什么东西那么重要？它必须和帕姆一起去纽约市。
Apparently, her weird spindly, plasticky desk decoration, she can't live without it. I put the multicolored sphere bobble thing. Yeah. We've talked about it on the podcast before. I get that maybe she needed to clear her desk for whoever's filling in for her. Just leave the box. Yeah. Put it in a storeroom and get it out when you get back.
显然，她那奇怪的、细长的、塑料质感的办公桌装饰品，她没有它就活不下去了。我放了那个多色球体弹簧摆件。是的。我们以前在播客里讨论过。我明白也许她需要为接替她的人清理办公桌。那就把箱子留下。是的。把它放在储藏室里，等你回来时再拿出来。
There's nothing in that box you need at Pratt, Pam. Nothing. But Pam has a talking head. It's super cute. I loved doing it where I say, what up 212? I hate to tell you, Pam, the area code for Pratt, which is located in Brooklyn, is 718. No, Pam. But it's okay.
那个箱子里没有什么东西是你去普瑞特艺术学院时必需的，帕姆，什么都没有。但帕姆有一个单人访谈。超级可爱。我很喜欢做那个访谈，我说，212区好啊？我很遗憾地告诉你，帕姆，普瑞特艺术学院所在的布鲁克林的区号其实是718。不，帕姆。但没关系。
You're trying to be all New York-y. You're trying to be cute. It's cute. Yeah, that's the Manhattan area code. Mm-hmm. Well, at five minutes, 13 seconds, there's going to be a storyline that starts, which is Andy and Angela wedding planning. There's lots of delicious stuff.
你想表现得很有纽约范儿。你想表现得很可爱。这很可爱。是的，那是曼哈顿的区号。嗯-哼。好吧，在五分钟13秒时，将有一条剧情线开始，那就是安吉拉和安迪的婚礼筹备。有很多美味的内容。
There's lots more in deleted scenes. All of this wedding planning is just absolutely stressing Angela out and making her more and more irritated at Andy. This is how he walks up to her. Angela. Ella. Ella. Ella.
被删减的片段里还有很多。所有这些婚礼筹备简直让安吉拉压力山大，并让她对安迪越来越恼火。他是这样走向她的。安吉拉。埃拉。埃拉。埃拉。
Ella. Under my angela. Ella. Ella. Ella. Eh. Eh. What?
埃拉。在我的安吉拉之下。埃拉。埃拉。埃拉。呃。呃。什么？
I loved it so much. That's how they're starting their conversation. Andy's excited. He says every little boy fantasizes about his fairy tale wedding. Ding, ding, ding, ding. This is when they had to go in and digitally change his shirt and tie in post-production because the writers wanted to move this talking head here. It had been in a different place in the story.
我太喜欢了。他们是这样开始对话的。安迪很兴奋。他说每个小男孩都幻想过他的童话婚礼。叮，叮，叮，叮。这就是他们不得不进去在后期制作中以数字方式改变他的衬衫和领带的时候，因为编剧们想把这个单人访谈移到这里。它原本在故事中的另一个地方。
His tie and his shirt are digital. Because they had to make it match the scene with Angela? That's right. My mind is blown. Oh, yeah. They had to change all of that in post so they could move this talking head up. Well, in the scene with Angela, he is suggesting that they get married at the breakers in Rhode Island, this famous estate.
他的领带和衬衫是数字合成的。因为他们必须让它与安吉拉的场景相匹配？没错。我的天哪。哦，是的。他们不得不在后期改变所有这些，以便他们能够把这个单人访谈提上来。好吧，在和安吉拉的场景中，他建议他们在罗德岛的“破浪者”庄园结婚，这是一座著名的庄园。
Angela doesn't like it. He said this is really important to his family because this is where his parents decided not to get divorced. How romantic. Yes. That's where you want to get married. I looked this place up. It was built back in 1893 as a summer home.
安吉拉不喜欢它。他说这对他的家人真的很重要，因为这是他父母决定不离婚的地方。多么浪漫。是的。这就是你想结婚的地方。我查了这个地方。它建于1893年，作为一处避暑别墅。
Not even a main residence. It was built by the Vanderbilt family. It cost $7 million to build back then. Back then. Back then, it took two years. Is it massive? Yeah. There are 70 rooms in the house.
甚至不是主住宅。这是范德比尔特家族建造的。当时造价高达700万美元。当时。当时，花了两年时间。它很大吗？对。房子里有70个房间。
Oh, come on. The Great Hall. 70 rooms for their summer residence. Right. The Great Hall has 45-foot ceilings. There's a gold room that was actually built in Europe and then shipped to the United States and reassembled in Newport. Good Lord.
哦，拜托。大厅。他们的避暑别墅有70个房间。没错。大厅的天花板有45英尺高。还有一个黄金房间，其实是在欧洲建造的，然后运到美国并在纽波特重新组装。天哪。
It is estimated to be worth $150 million today. That one room? No, the whole house. Oh. I know. I see how you went there because of the way I structured that. Oh my gosh. So $150 million?
据估计，它今天的价值为1.5亿美元。就那一个房间？不，整栋房子。哦。我知道。我明白你为什么会顺着我的话那样想了。天哪。所以是1.5亿美元？
Yeah. It now belongs to the Preservation Society of Newport County. It is available for tours. It's about 300,000 visitors annually, but get this, great grandchildren still live there on the third floor during the summer. Oh my gosh. But you can't tour their private residence area when you tour the house. This is like going to Buckingham Palace.
对。它现在属于纽波特县保护协会。它对游客开放。每年大约有30万名游客，但你听着，夏天的时候，曾孙辈们仍然住在三楼。天哪。但你在参观房子时，是不能参观他们的私人住宅区的。这就像去白金汉宫一样。
I always wonder about that. Like you live there, but there's tours. What's it like to live in a house? Yeah. What is that? I don't know. 70 rooms. Maybe you don't even know.
我总是对这一点感到好奇。就像你住在那里，但这里有参观。住在这样的房子里是什么感觉？对。那是什么？我不知道。70个房间。也许你甚至都不知道。
Are you not giving tours of your home, Angela, to tourists while you live there? Welcome to come over. The whole bathroom, you have to jiggle the handle. It's a double flusher. It doesn't quite do it the first time. Well, all of this wedding planning stresses Angela out and she immediately pages Dwight. And they rendezvous in the warehouse, Angela comes out of the little warehouse. I don't even know what you call it, storage room where they meet up.
安吉拉，你住在家的时候，不会带游客参观你的家吧？欢迎过来。整个浴室，你得晃晃把手。它是双冲水的。第一次往往冲不干净。好吧，所有这些婚礼筹备工作让安吉拉压力山大，她立刻传呼德怀特。他们在仓库碰头，安吉拉从那个小仓库里出来。我甚至不知道该怎么称呼它，他们碰面的储藏室。
And she says, look, that was the last time I have a fiance I very much like. All right. So there are deleted scenes that throughout weight loss one and two really show Angela struggling between wanting to be excited for the wedding and also that Andy is driving her crazy. And then she runs to Dwight. It's sort of this love triangle. And the documentary crew clearly decided to ask her about it.
她说，听着，那是我最后一次有一个我非常喜欢的未婚夫了。好的。所以有一些被删减的片段，在《减肥》第一集和第二集中，真正展示了安吉拉在想要为婚礼感到兴奋以及安迪快把她逼疯之间的挣扎。然后她跑去找德怀特。这有点像个三角恋。纪录片摄制组显然决定就此询问她。
And here was her response. It's in the deleted scenes. No, I'm not cheating on anybody. I have one fiance and I have physical relations with one man. Hmm. She keeps it separate. One guy shall marry and one guy for the shag. I guess Angela Martin is like, you know, once I'm at the aisle, it's done.
她的回答是这样的。这在被删减的片段里。不，我没有对不起任何人。我只有一个未婚夫，我只和一个男人有身体关系。嗯。她分得很清。一个男人负责结婚，一个男人负责鱼水之欢。我想安吉拉·马丁的意思是，你知道的，一旦我走上红毯，就结束了。
Yeah. Once I speak my vows, I'll stop sleeping with Dwight. But for right now, I am engaged. This is a period of, I guess, non-commitment, but commitment. I don't know. I don't know how she's gonna deal with how that crazy Andy makes her once they're married. What will her outlet be? But yes, I thought that was interesting because there's that moment when she comes out of
对。一旦我宣誓完毕，我就不再和德怀特睡了。但目前为止，我订婚了。这是一个，我猜既不承诺又承诺的时期。我不知道。我不知道等他们结婚后，她将如何应对那个疯狂的安迪把她逼成什么样。她的宣泄口会是什么？但是，是的，我觉得这很有意思，因为有这样一个时刻，她从
the storage room with Dwight, where she sees the camera, right? And this talking head would have happened immediately after where they would have confronted her, which I thought was pretty ballsy for the documentary crew. Well, they need to follow up on these things. Now we have a scene where Michael, through his window, sees that Pam is getting into her car, she's getting ready to drive to Pratt, and he has not said his goodbye. No, he hasn't. And I want you to know, I know whose office it was that he was in.
带着德怀特的储藏室里出来，她看到了镜头，对吧？这个“面对镜头独白”本应该紧接着发生，他们会当面质问她，我觉得对于纪录片摄制组来说这挺有种的。好吧，他们需要跟进这些事情。现在我们有一个场景，迈克尔透过窗户看到潘正在上车，她正准备开车去普瑞特艺术学院，而他还没有向她道别。不，他没有。我想让你知道，我知道他当时在谁的办公室里。
Was it Paul Lieberstein's? No, it was Jen Saladas. Okay. There you go. If you're curious, that's the writer's room that Michael was in. And poor Michael, he practically wipes out two flights of stairs trying to get to Pam so he could say goodbye. It's so funny.
是保罗·利伯斯坦的吗？不，是珍·萨拉达斯的。好吧。给你。如果你好奇的话，那是迈克尔所在的编剧办公室。可怜的迈克尔，他几乎连跑带跌地冲了两层楼梯，只为了赶上潘好跟她道别。太搞笑了。
And he wrote her a poem, but he left it upstairs. It ends with the word seagulls. Here's what I have to say about this scene. Pam is going to drive to New York in a pencil skirt. Also, here was my question. Where's she going to park her car? There's nowhere to park your car in New York City. You have to pay for a parking spot.
他给她写了一首诗，但他把它忘在楼上了。结尾的词是海鸥。关于这个场景，我想说的是。潘竟然穿着铅笔裙开车去纽约。另外，我的问题是。她把车停在哪儿？在纽约市根本没地方停车。你得付停车费。
Well, she's going to Brooklyn. She's going to like a college campus. Do you think they have a spot for her? I think they do. Oh, okay. I think there's a campus parking lot. Okay, okay, okay. I'm not worried about that.
嗯，她要去布鲁克林。她要去一个类似大学校园的地方。你觉得他们有她的车位吗？我想他们有。哦，好吧。我想那里有校园停车场。好吧，好吧，好吧。我不担心这个。
I'm worried about why did she come into work even for a half day? Why didn't she change her clothes? She's going to arrive at Pratt in a pencil skirt and pantyhose. Mm-hmm. Really? Really? Pam. I hope there's parking.
我担心的是她为什么还要来上班，哪怕只是半天？她为什么不换身衣服？她穿着铅笔裙和连裤袜去普瑞特。嗯哼。真的吗？真的吗？潘。我希望那儿有停车位。
Well, listen, I wanted you to know, Randy Cordray shared that this parking lot scene took place on an incredibly hot day. It was like triple-digit weather in Los Angeles and, you know, Steve runs hot anyway and he had to run into this scene and it was super hot in a suit. Well, Phil Shea found a cooling vest that Steve could wear under his suit to help keep him cool. It's the type of vest that marathon runners and athletes have. They use it to cool their body temperature down.
好吧，听着，我想让你们知道，兰迪·科德雷分享说，这个停车场场景拍摄于一个热得不可思议的日子。洛杉矶的天气就像三位数的高温，你知道的，史蒂夫本来就容易出汗，他不得不冲进这个场景中，穿着西装超级热。好吧，菲尔·谢伊找到了一件冷却背心，史蒂夫可以穿在西装里面来保持凉爽。这是马拉松运动员和运动员穿的那种背心。他们用它来降低体温。
It has these little frozen gel packs and Steve had that on under his suit. I've never heard of this thing, which makes sense to me because I would never seek it out. I would never think how can I be colder in any situation. No, never. It's a whole thing. I Googled it. There's many different types of cooling vests that you can get.
它有这些小冰冻凝胶包，史蒂夫在西装里面穿了这个。我从来没听说过这东西，这对我来说很合理，因为我绝不会主动去找它。我绝不会在任何情况下都去想我怎么才能更冷。不，绝不。这可是一整套。我谷歌了一下。你可以买到许多不同类型的冷却背心。
Athletes use them, soldiers use them. I mean, you know, it's like a whole thing. You know what I do own? What? A warming vest. I have a vest and you put little hot packs in it and it keeps you warm. I bought it so that I could watch my son play ice hockey outdoors. Yeah.
运动员使用它们，士兵使用它们。我的意思是，你知道，这就像是一整套。你知道我有什么吗？什么？一件保暖背心。我有一件背心，你在里面放上小热包，它就能让你保暖。我买它是为了看我儿子在户外打冰球。对。
Well, we used to stuff those little hot pocket thingies, what do you call them? Not the food hot pockets. What are they called? I love the idea of us having a vest filled with hot pockets though. And then if you get hungry, yeah, it's a snack as well. It keeps you warm and low. Listen, listen, on the office, I had one skirt that had two little stitch pockets in the back and I had one little tiny stitch pocket in the front.
嗯，我们以前会把那些小热袋塞进去，叫什么来着？不是那种食物热袋。它们叫什么？不过我倒是挺喜欢我们穿一件塞满热袋的背心的主意。然后如果你饿了，是的，它也是个零食。它能让你保暖又……听着，听着，在《办公室》里，我有一条裙子，后面有两个小针线口袋，前面有一个小小的针线口袋。
They would give us those little hot pack things. Little hand warmers. Little hand warmers. I would stick two in my shoes. I would stick one in that front pocket, two in my back pocket. I'd stick a few in my bra. Same. Yeah, I remember that.
他们会给我们那些小热包。小暖手宝。小暖手宝。我会把两个塞进鞋子里。我会把一个塞在前口袋里，两个塞在后口袋里。我会在胸罩里塞几个。一样。对，我记得那个。
Yeah. And if my sweater had pockets, I'd stick them in there. I'd stick so many of those on my body when we were filming outside when it was cold. One time our camera operator Matt Stone was like, and just don't take this the wrong way, but I can see lumps in your butt on camera. They don't look human. Like human lumps. I was like, dang it.
对。如果我的毛衣有口袋，我会把它们塞进去。天气冷在外面拍摄时，我会在身上塞好多那些东西。有一次我们的摄像师马特·石像是在说，别介意啊，我能看到你屁股上有隆起，在镜头里。它们看起来不像人类。就像人的肿块一样。当时我就想，该死。
And I had to take my little heater things out of my pockets. Well, I can't believe that they got a cooling vest and I'm glad they did. I am too. I thought that was so smart. Mm-hmm. Well, it's time for another weigh-in. Big announcement, they lost 31 pounds. Wow.
我不得不把我的小加热器从口袋里掏出来。好吧，我真不敢相信他们弄到了一件冷却背心，我很高兴他们这么做了。我也是。我觉得这太聪明了。嗯哼。好吧，又到了称体重的时候了。重大宣布，他们减了31磅。哇。
Michael and Holly are so excited they're going to do a wrap. It's the most adorable thing. Because they're so dorky and cute together. Well, a little wrap trivia is that they have about 10 minutes of them wrapping. Even though the part that you see in the show was completely scripted, even down to Holly like rubbing her jacket. Yeah, the wiki-wiki what? All of that was scripted.
迈克尔和霍莉兴奋得要来一段说唱。这是最可爱的事情。因为他们俩在一起时既书呆子气又可爱。好吧，关于说唱的一个小冷知识是，他们有大约10分钟的说唱。尽管你在节目中看到的那部分完全是按剧本演的，甚至细致到霍莉揉搓她的夹克。对，维基-维基什么？所有这些都是按剧本演的。
All of that was scripted, but they did go on and on. And Amy Ryan gave an interview where she said this was her favorite scene to shoot because they had so much fun. The crew said the same thing. They said it was so much fun that those two just went off and that the chemistry was just so apparent. I think this was the scene when they were shooting, when they realized, oh, yeah. These two.
所有这些都是按剧本演的，但他们确实滔滔不绝地说个没完。艾米·瑞安在接受采访时说，这是她最喜欢拍摄的场景，因为他们玩得太开心了。剧组也这么说。他们说太有趣了，这两人直接即兴发挥，而且那种化学反应实在是太明显了。我想这就是他们在拍摄时意识到，哦，是的。这两个人。
True love. Yeah. Well, now it's week three and there is a new receptionist in town. Yes. Ronnie. Yeah. Ronnie played by Dale Raul. She has been in a ton of stuff.
真爱。好吧，现在是第三周，镇上迎来了一名前台。是的。罗妮。对。由戴尔·劳尔扮演的罗妮。她演过海量的作品。
She was Maxine in True Blood. Oh, Maxine Fortenberry. I love True Blood. She was fantastic. Of course you would know that. Yes. I have a crossover connection with Dale. Tell me.
她在《真爱如血》里演麦克辛。哦，麦克辛·福腾伯里。我喜欢《真爱如血》。她演得棒极了。你当然会知道这个。对。我和戴尔有过交集。告诉我。
We were both on Fresh Off the Boat. Well, there you go. Not Monk, surprisingly, but Fresh Off the Boat. Well, she will come back in season six. This is not the last we're going to see of Ronnie. Meanwhile, we're going to see Pam in her first class. She looks so cute. She has like, I'm calling it the college ponytail.
我们俩都演过《初来乍到》。好吧，那就对了。不是《神探阿蒙》，出乎意料，而是《初来乍到》。好吧，她会在第六季回归。这并不是我们最后一次见到罗妮。与此同时，我们要看潘的第一节课。她看起来太可爱了。她扎着那种，我称之为大学马尾辫的头发。
She wears this really cute ponytail at school. All right, the ponytail is the only thing that's cute about Pam. Are you kidding? I thought you looked so cute in all of your college scenes. Did you notice how young everyone else is in the class? Oh, you stop it. No, but this was a deliberate choice. Well, OK.
她在学校扎着这个非常可爱的马尾辫。好吧，这个马尾辫是潘身上唯一可爱的地方。你在开玩笑吧？我觉得你在所有的大学场景里都看起来超级可爱。你注意到班里其他人有多年轻了吗？哦，行了。不，但这可是个刻意的选择。好吧，好吧。
Pam is in her late 20s. She like how immediately I like stand up for my best friend. I'm like, you stop it. You are beautiful. You look just as young as those other ones. That's right. And you are smart. OK.
潘已经快三十岁了。她——看我多快就为我最好朋友辩护的。我说“行了”。你很漂亮。你看起来和那些人一样年轻。没错。而且你很聪明。好吧。
Thank you. You're welcome. So I was not being down on myself. I was just pointing out a deliberate production choice. Pam is in her late 20s, and they made sure that everyone in this class, that the background performers were all much younger. They're just starting off in college, right? Pam's going back to school, and they did want to create this story for Pam that she
谢谢。不客气。所以我不是在贬低自己。我只是在指出一个刻意的制作选择。潘已经快三十岁了，他们确保了这个班里的每个人，背景演员都年轻得多。他们才刚刚开始上大学，对吧？潘要重返校园，他们确实想为潘打造这样一条故事线，即她
is kind of, you know. Yeah. I don't know. What am I saying? What do they call it? A non-traditional student. There you go. Not only that, she's in the wrong class.
有点，你知道的。对。我不知道。他们管这叫什么？非传统学生。这就对了。不仅如此，她还上错课了。
The teacher, who was played by Sandra Lowe, Professor Monahan. She's got that zinger of a joke about Zaf chancery, you know. Which by the way, I read a Reddit thread where people were like, that doesn't apply. That's wrong. Oh. Oh my. Well, Pam does not end up leaving the class. And we got some mail.
由桑德拉·洛饰演的老师莫纳汉教授。她讲了一个关于扎夫教务处的绝妙笑话，你知道的。顺便说一句，我读过一个红迪网的帖子，人们在上面说，那根本不适用。那是错的。哦。哦天哪。好吧，潘并没有退课。我们收到了一些邮件。
People are like, Pam has been so good about standing up for herself. Why doesn't she just leave the class? I don't know. I sympathized. I felt like she's new here. She feels out of place. She just got singled out. She's going to tuck her head down and know she'll do it right the next time.
人们说，潘在为自己挺身而出这件事上一直做得很好。她为什么不直接退课？我不知道。我很同情她。我觉得她对这里很陌生。她觉得自己格格不入。她刚刚被单独点名了。她会把头埋起来，心想下次她会做好的。
Yeah. But I guess it's going to mean she misses her actual first real class. Back in the office, Holly hears this coughing, right? She's at her cubicle. Kelly is coughing. She sounds sick. Did you notice on Holly's desk what her nameplate says? Yes.
对。但我想这意味着她错过了她真正的第一堂正经课。回到办公室，霍莉听到这阵咳嗽声，对吧？她在她的办公桌前。凯利在咳嗽。她听起来生病了。你注意到霍莉的桌子上她的名牌写的是什么了吗？是的。
Her name is Hollis. And then in quotes, Holly, P, Flax. I did notice that. So that's her real name. Her name is Hollis. Hollis. Kelly has a talking head where she says she's on the third day of her cleanse diet, where she's doing the lemon juice, maple syrup, and cayenne pepper and water.
她的名字是霍利斯。然后在引号里写着，霍莉，P，弗拉克克斯。我注意到了。所以那是她的真名。她的名字叫霍利斯。霍利斯。凯利有一个面对镜头的独白，她说这是她进行排毒减肥饮食的第三天，她只喝柠檬汁、枫糖浆、辣椒粉和水。
That's all she's allowed to have. Angela, have you ever done any of these fad diets? I haven't, but I had a roommate who did something with cayenne pepper and water. And I think it just gives you the runs, right? You just poop. You know, I got approached to do an ad for this diet tea that's supposed to flatten your tummy. So you drink the tea and it flattens your tummy.
她只能吃这些。安吉拉，你做过这些减肥流行饮食吗？我没有，但我有个室友做过某种加了辣椒粉和水的东西。我觉得那只会让你拉肚子，对吧？你就是一直在跑厕所。你知道的，有人找我拍广告，推销一种据说能让小腹平坦的减肥茶。所以你喝这种茶，它就能让你的小腹平坦。
How? By making you poop a lot. But it was like a cleansing tea. And I was like, well, first of all, I'm not going to do an ad for anything I don't believe in. So send me the tea and we'll see what happens. Did you drink the tea? I was doing splitting up together at the time and I was talking to Oliver Hudson about it
怎么做到？让你狂拉肚子。但它就像是一种排毒茶。我就想，好吧，首先，我绝不会为任何我不相信的东西拍广告。所以把茶寄给我，我们看看会发生什么。你喝了那茶吗？我当时正在拍《我爱上的人对我说了谎》，我正和奥利弗·哈德森谈论这件事
and he said, I'll do it with you. Let's both do the tea and see if we get flat tummies. He's so funny. But I can so hear him saying that because he's just like, let's do it. He was all in. So I asked for two packages of the tea. Oliver and I started doing it, Angela. Did you poop?
他说，我和你一起。咱俩一起喝茶，看看小腹会不会变平坦。他太搞笑了。但我完全能想象他说这话的样子，因为他就是那种人，说“咱们干吧”。他全力以赴。所以我索要了两包茶。我和奥利弗开始喝了，安吉拉。你拉肚子了吗？
First of all, I gained weight. What? Second of all, we're just pooping and farting. Oh, no. We're trying to work and do our scenes. Oh, no. The crew was like, stop drinking the tea, you guys. You're farting them out.
首先，我增重了。什么？其次，我们俩一直在拉肚子和放屁。哦，不。我们试图工作和拍戏。哦，不。剧组的人说，你们俩别喝茶了。你们把屁都放出来了。
They're like, seriously, we cannot have the two leads of our show drinking this tea. Being so flatulent on set. Ruining everything. So I just, I don't know. I just don't do this stuff. Well, you know, my husband, he's super healthy and he just makes really good choices about what he eats and he exercises. It's really annoying his ability to be so consistent.
他们就像是，说真的，我们不能让节目的两位主演喝这种茶。在片场一直放屁。把一切都搞砸了。所以我只是，我不知道。我就是不做这种事。好吧，你知道的，我丈夫，他超级健康，他对自己的饮食做出了非常好的选择，而且他会锻炼。他那种能够如此自律的能力真的很烦人。
My heart is struggle is consistency, you know, just like making that space for myself. And I think it's even like when you peel back the layer, it's like making that time for yourself and it's just a hard thing to do. Yeah. Well, I think we should take a break because I need a moment to center myself before Jan comes into the office. Oh, oh yes. And there's some really good Jan stuff I want to share.
我的心魔是自律，你知道的，就像是为自己腾出那个空间。而且我觉得甚至就像当你剥开这一层时，它就像是为自己抽出那个时间，这是一件很难做到的事。对。好吧，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为我需要花点时间调整一下状态，然后珍就要进办公室了。哦，哦对了。而且有些非常棒的关于珍的料我想分享。
All right. We'll be right back. We are back and so is Jan. Oh yeah. Jan enters the office and tells Ronnie to make her some copies of a document on canary yellow paper. Oh yeah. She walks in like she owns the place.
好。我们马上回来。我们回来了，珍也回来了。哦耶。珍走进办公室，告诉罗妮帮她把一份文件复印几份，印在金丝雀黄的纸上。哦耶。她走进来的时候，感觉这地方就像是她开的一样。
She also does not acknowledge that she's speaking to a person she's never met. Oh yeah. That's true. I'm going to be wondering if Jan is entertaining Michael being in her life again so she can just use him and use the office. She's getting free copies, right? Yeah. Well, in the deleted scenes, there's a little bit of a runner about this.
而且她也没有承认她正在和一个从未谋面的人说话。哦耶。确实如此。我会好奇珍是不是在客套地让迈克尔重新回到她的生活中，这样她就可以利用他并利用办公室。她在白嫖复印件，对吧？对。好吧，在被删减的片段中，有一个关于这个的小桥段。
She is giving Michael like a list of things she needs him to do. All her errands, go to the dry cleaners. She hands him a bag and like grocery shopping, et cetera, like Michael is her personal assistant. And then when he kind of boxed at anything, she's like, well, I thought you wanted to help. Wow. So to me, I feel like Jan is using him. For sure.
她给迈克尔列了一张她需要他做的事情的清单。她所有的差事，去干洗店。她递给他一个袋子，还有去杂货店购物等等，就像迈克尔是她的私人助理一样。然后当他对任何事表现出抗拒时，她说，哦，我还以为你想帮忙呢。哇。所以在我看来，珍在利用他。肯定的。
Jim has this talking head where he says Michael led us to believe he was the father of Jan's baby by telling us he was the father of Jan's baby. Well, this talking head would have continued and they had to trim it. And Jim then holds up an email and says, but then Jan sent this email to everyone. And here's what Jan's email said, Hi everyone, Jan here writing to share some wonderful news and to squash a rumor. First, the great news I am expecting. The beautiful baby girl inside me will be ready to meet the world this fall, just a
吉姆有一个面对镜头的独白，他说迈克尔让我们以为他是珍孩子的父亲，因为他告诉我们他是珍孩子的父亲。好吧，这段独白本该继续下去，但他们不得不删减它。然后吉姆举起一封电子邮件说，但随后珍把这封电子邮件发给了所有人。珍的邮件是这样写的：嗨，大家好，我是珍，写信来分享一些好消息并澄清一个谣言。首先，好消息是我怀孕了。我体内的美丽女婴将于今年秋天准备好与世界见面，就在
few months before the launch of the new Serenity by Jan line. Shameless plug. I know. Don't hate me. Lol. Anyway, I also wanted to clarify that the father is not anyone that you or I have ever met. Remember, no matter how excited someone is about my baby, it does not make them the father.
珍的全新“宁静”系列发布前几个月。赤裸裸的植入广告。我知道。不要恨我。哈哈。不管怎样，我还想澄清的是，孩子的父亲不是你或我见过的任何人。记住，无论谁对我的孩子多么兴奋，这并不意味着他们就是父亲。
Best Jan. P.S. hope to ship you something soon. That's amazing. Yeah. So she sent that email to everyone in the office. Well, Holly would like to know who is Jan. She says who's that woman in Michael's office with the feet? Because Michael is rubbing Jan's feet.
祝好，珍。附言：希望很快能给你们寄点东西。太惊人了。对。所以她把那封电子邮件发给了办公室里的每个人。好吧，霍莉想知道珍是谁。她说迈克尔办公室里那个脚放在那里的女人是谁？因为迈克尔在给珍揉脚。
Oscar explains that she's Michael's ex-girlfriend and Holly immediately decides, Yes, you can give your yoga teacher my number. I want to date your hot yoga teacher. Yeah. His hot hot yoga teacher because he teaches hot yoga and he's hot. So I'm sure he's very bendy. Yeah. Yeah.
奥斯卡解释说她是迈克尔的前女友，霍莉立刻决定：行，你可以把我的电话号码给你的瑜伽老师。我想和你的热瑜伽老师约会。对。他的火辣热瑜伽老师，因为他教热瑜伽而且很火辣。所以我确信他身体非常柔软。对。对。
Then Holly overhears Angela berating Kevin for being an idiot and Holly is going to come to Kevin's defense because remember Dwight told Holly that Kevin was there as part of a special work program. Yeah. When Dwight was hazing her. Yeah. Oh, she runs over to Angela and she's like, how dare you? You don't speak to him like that.
然后霍莉无意中听到安吉拉训斥凯文是个白痴，霍莉决定为凯文挺身而出，因为记不记得德怀特曾对霍莉说凯文在那儿是特殊工作项目的一部分。对。当时德怀特正在对她进行恶整。对。哦，她跑向安吉拉说，你怎么敢？你不能那样跟他说话。
And this is when everyone realizes, including Kevin, what Dwight told Holly. Angela is so delighted by this moment. She can't stop smiling. No. She loves that Holly has been humiliated. For Kevin, he's crushed. This means that Holly has not been paying attention to him because she wants to date him.
这时所有人都意识到了，包括凯文，德怀特对霍莉说了什么。安吉拉对这一刻感到高兴极了。她笑得合不拢嘴。不。她喜欢霍莉被羞辱的样子。对凯文来说，他心碎了。这意味着霍莉一直没有关注他，因为她想和他约会。
No. He's realizing. Well, now Andy is going to approach Angela in the kitchen. He has made non-refundable deposits at four different wedding locations. Hot air balloons over Napa Valley, world famous Walt Disney's Epcot Center, scuba diving wedding in the Bahamas and the Wilkes Bar Marriott Ballroom C, to which she replies, dangerous, tacky, sharks haunted. And no.
不。他意识到了。好吧，现在安迪要在厨房里接近安吉拉了。他在四个不同的婚礼场地支付了不可退还的押金。纳帕谷的热气球、世界著名的华特迪士尼Epcot中心、巴哈马群岛的水肺潜水婚礼以及威尔克斯巴里万豪酒店C宴会厅，安吉拉对此回复道：危险、俗气、闹鬼鲨鱼。还有不。
And just in general. And no. And of course, this means Angela and Dwight are going to hook up again. We had a fan question. Kayla would like to know when Dwight slaps Angela's butt, was that scripted because she thought your reaction was very genuine. You were surprised. No.
而且总的来说。还有不。当然，这意味着安吉拉和德怀特又要搞在一起了。我们有一个粉丝提问。凯拉想知道当德怀特拍安吉拉的屁股时，那是按剧本演的吗？因为她觉得你的反应非常真实。你很吃惊。不。
That was improvised. Mm-hmm. That was Rainn Wilson. But now listen, you guys. Rainn and I were very, very good friends and we would always do a few takes where we would try to surprise each other a little bit within the boundaries of what I knew would not make anyone uncomfortable and vice versa. Right.
那是即兴发挥。嗯哼。那是雷恩·威尔森。但是现在听着，伙计们。雷恩和我是非常非常好的朋友，我们总是会拍上几次，试图在不让任何人感到不舒服的底线内给对方一些小惊喜，反之亦然。没错。
And so, no, that was Rainn just mixing it up and catching me off guard, which is why my reaction is so earnest. We also got mail from Alice, who would like to ask Angela in your talking head afterwards, was any of that improvised because it's one of my all-time favorites? You know what? People quote this talking head to me and it was completely scripted. And it read like this, I have a nice comforter and several cozy pillows. I usually read a chapter of a book and it slides out by 8.30.
所以，不，那是雷恩只是即兴发挥，让我措手不及，这就是为什么我的反应那么真诚。我们还收到了爱丽丝的邮件，她想问安吉拉，在你随后的面对镜头独白中，有哪部分是即兴发挥吗？因为这是我历来最喜欢的片段之一。你知道吗？人们经常引用这段独白给我听，而它完全是按照剧本演的。台词是这样的：我有一个不错的舒适被子和几个温馨的枕头。我通常读一章书，然后在8点30分准时滑入梦乡。
That's how I sleep at night. Completely scripted. You go to bed at 8.30. I know. I have lots of cats to take care of. They get up early. Well, now, Jim and Pam are going to talk via video call. You guys, old tech alert, this was a real big deal.
我晚上就是这样睡觉的。完全按剧本演的。你8点30分就上床睡觉。我知道。我有好多猫要照顾。它们起得早。好吧，现在，吉姆和潘要通过视频通话聊天了。伙计们，老科技警报，这可是件了不得的大事。
This was an actual live eye chat. Remember eye chat? Yeah. Yeah. This is before Zoom. This is before FaceTime. Yeah. And Dwight is annoyed.
这是一个真正的实时视频聊天。还记得视频聊天吗？对。对。这是在Zoom之前。这是在FaceTime之前。对。德怀特很恼火。
Michael is so excited and picks up the computer and wants to show Pam all around. I know, which is making her a little sick. She's like, can you please put me down? I thought it was so cute. Guys, this happened in real time. We had some questions from Alice R and Breanna P. How'd you shoot the video chat scenes? Well, it was live. They built a little set over on the warehouse set to look like my dorm room at Pratt.
迈克尔兴奋极了，拿起电脑想让潘看周围的一切。我知道，这让她有点恶心。她说，你能放下我吗？我觉得这太可爱了。伙计们，这是实时发生的。我们收到来自爱丽丝·R和布里安娜·P的一些问题。你们是怎么拍摄视频聊天场景的？嗯，那是直播。他们在仓库布景那边搭建了一个小布景，看起来像我在普瑞特的宿舍房间。
And I sat there and we did this live. It was really cute. Yeah. And I have to say, I was really excited because during most of this episode, I was not on our set. I was really filming on location to film Pam's art school. And so for this day, I just remember how excited I was, even though I was all the way on the warehouse set, I was able to come over for hot snack.
我坐在那儿，我们进行了直播。真的超级可爱。对。而且我必须说，我真的很兴奋，因为在这集的绝大部分时间里，我都不在我们的片场。我真的在实景地拍摄潘的艺术学校。所以对于这一天，我只记得我是多么兴奋，尽管我一直在仓库布景那边，我还是能够过来吃热乎的小吃。
Yes. I stayed for lunch. Yes. This was one of the hardest things for us as BFFs is when you were at the Pratt School of Art. Yep. You were not on our set. You were on location.
对。我留下来吃午饭了。对。作为闺蜜，这对我们来说最难的事情之一就是当你在普瑞特艺术学院的时候。没错。你不在我们的片场。你在外景地。
I was so excited you were there. And one thing I want to share about this that Randy talked about in the DVD commentary is that this live eye chat, Jenna, caused all kinds of technical problems. I remember. Yeah. I remember because we had to start and stop. Here's what happened. The wireless microwave system on the side of the cameras would get triggered whenever
我太高兴你在那儿了。关于这一点，兰迪在DVD评论中谈到了一件事我想分享，就是这个实上的实时视频聊天，珍娜，引起了各种技术问题。我记得。对。我记得因为我们不得不停下来又开始。事情是这样的。每当
Steve picked up the laptop and walked around with you. It would shut the cameras off, which meant we got to hang out a little bit because they had to sort that out. I just remember shooting the talking head and I thought it was so cute the way they put the computer on the chair. I did too. Well now the gang is going to weigh in again. And guess what?
史蒂夫拿起笔记本电脑带着你四处走动时，摄像机侧面的无线微波系统就会被触发。它会关掉摄像机，这意味着我们得以一起闲逛一会儿，因为他们必须把这个问题解决。我只记得拍摄那个面对镜头独白，我觉得他们把电脑放在椅子上的方式太可爱了。我也是。好吧，现在大家要再次称体重了。你猜怎么着？
They've gained five pounds and then Kelly passes out. Yeah. And we go to commercial. We come back with some real Phyllis Sass. Mm-hmm. Phyllis is super smug with Angela and she's planning Stanley's birthday party and she's just giving Angela marching orders. She is.
他们胖了五磅，然后凯利晕倒了。对。我们进入广告时间。我们带着菲利斯的犀利吐槽回来了。嗯哼。菲利斯在安吉拉面前超级自鸣得意，她在筹划斯坦利的生日派对，她简直是在对安吉拉发号施令。她确实是。
She would like to get some cake. And anytime Angela seems like she might disagree, Phyllis just kind of gives a little look like we will be doing it this way and here's why. Yeah. And there was more Phyllis Sass in the deleted scenes. She was given Angela grief this whole episode. While we talked about this at the end of Goodbye Toby, Phyllis catches Dwight and Angela getting it on in the office and we wondered, what does this mean?
她想弄点蛋糕吃。每当安吉拉看起来可能不同意时，菲利斯就会露出一副“我们就得这么做，原因如下”的表情。对。在被删减的片段中还有更多菲利斯的犀利吐槽。这一整集她都在给安吉拉找麻烦。正如我们在《告别托比》结尾所谈到的，菲利斯抓包了德怀特和安吉拉在办公室里亲热，我们纳闷，这意味着什么？
Well, it has gone to Phyllis's head. She has power. Mm-hmm. Holly suggests that they do fruit instead of cake. Michael comes in, he's going to weigh in, he suddenly has a goatee, no explanation. Yeah. But he has a goatee. Kelly Canley said that goatee took an hour to put on, so they had to factor that into
好吧，这冲昏了菲利斯的头脑。她有权力了。嗯哼。霍莉建议他们吃水果代替蛋糕。迈克尔进来了，他要来称体重，他突然留起了山羊胡，没有任何解释。对。但他确实留了山羊胡。凯利·坎利说那个山羊胡花了一个小时才贴上，所以他们必须把这个时间计入当天的安排中。
the day. He didn't just grow a goatee? No. None of their goatees were real. No. That's what she said. No. None of them?
他不是自己长出来的山羊胡？没有。他们的山羊胡都不是真的。没有。她是这么说的。没有。一个都不是？
They were all put on and then they had to keep track that they were the right shape and size goatee throughout the episode for continuity and Kelly said at the time this aired they got some mail that a few of the goatees were off. Oh my gosh. Oh. Well Michael is going to take his goatee into the conference room and he's going to call a meeting. Yeah.
它们都是贴上去的，然后他们必须确保在整集中山羊胡的形状和大小都保持正确以维持连贯性，凯利说在这个节目播出时，他们收到了一些邮件说有几个山羊胡贴歪了。哦天哪。哦。好吧，迈克尔要带着他的山羊胡走进会议室，他要开个会。对。
Because he wants everyone to know what is the leading cause of death. It is obesity caused illness. He wants everyone to take this more seriously so they don't die of obesity. Yeah. Jim pledges to lose 65 pounds. He's being sarcastic. Michael doesn't get it. He's thrilled.
因为他想让每个人都知道导致死亡的主要原因是什么。那是肥胖引起的疾病。他想让每个人都更严肃对待这件事，这样他们就不会死于肥胖。对。吉姆承诺减掉65磅。他在开玩笑。迈克尔没听出来。他兴奋极了。
He says if everybody loses five pounds, that in addition to Jim's 65, we're going to win this thing. Well, Angela has presented Andy with her list of criteria for her wedding. It's pretty challenging. Here are the things she has to have in order to marry Andy. Okay. A thousand-year-old church in the continental United States. There has to be a rainbow, 24-hour veterinarian on call.
他说如果每个人都减掉五磅，再加上吉姆减掉的65磅，我们就能赢得这场比赛了。好吧，安吉拉向安迪展示了她对婚礼的条件清单。这相当具有挑战性。以下是她为了嫁给安迪必须具备的条件。好吧。美国本土有一座千年老教堂。必须有彩虹，有24小时待命的兽医。
And then she pages Dwight to meet her downstairs because she just can't really stand being around Andy. But Andy tells Angela, you know what? I don't care where we get married because all I care about is spending the rest of my life with you. This melts Angela's cold, cold heart. It does. And she does not show up for her rendezvous with Dwight in the warehouse.
然后她传呼德怀特到楼下去见她，因为她实在受不了和安迪待在一起。但安迪对安吉拉说，你知道吗？我不在乎我们在哪里结婚，因为我唯一在乎的就是和你度过余生。这融化了安吉拉冰冷的心。确实如此。而且她没有去仓库赴德怀特的约。
She gives Andy a little kiss. And of course he has to make a noise. He makes like a bow. Yeah. So there's a very sweet-deleted scene that shows Angela trying to bond with Andy over the wedding. It's in the break room and I titled it, Overly Animated Angela. We could get a cake shaped like your cat.
她给了安迪一个小小的吻。当然，他必须发出声音。他发出类似鞠躬的声音。对。所以有一个非常甜蜜的被删减片段展示了安吉拉试图通过婚礼与安迪建立感情。它在休息室里，我给它起名叫：表情过度的安吉拉。我们可以做一个形状像你猫的蛋糕。
They can do that? Yeah. Yeah. For you, my love, I will find the finest cake smith in all the land. And it brings me, sir, bakes a lot of frosting ham forest. What about when she's like, I don't know, a litter box? Hey! Right?
他们能做到吗？对。对。为了你，我的爱人，我将在全世界寻找最顶级的蛋糕大师。把我带去，先生，烘焙大量的糖霜火腿森林。当她说时，我不知道，一个猫砂盆？嘿！对吧？
I mean, is it gross or wonderful? Ah! I don't know! I'll be at my desk. Page me if you need me. Who are you? I know! Ah!
我的意思是，这很恶心还是棒极了？啊！我不知道！我要回我的座位去。如果需要的话呼我。你是谁？我知道！啊！
I don't know! Who is this person? I don't know. Oh, Overly Animated Angela, she was trying. Maybe he should just do some mad libs. You love those. I love mad libs and keep suggesting cakes that look like cats or cat accessories. It's a way to your heart.
我不知道！这个人是谁？我不知道。哦，表情过度的安吉拉，她一直在努力。也许他应该只做一些疯狂填词游戏。你很喜欢那些。我喜欢疯狂填词游戏，并不断建议做成猫或猫配饰形状的蛋糕。这是通往你心的捷径。
Well, Jim has arrived at Pam's dorm room. Did you notice that Pam is the resident advisor? I did. She's the RA. It's so perfect. It's perfect, but it's also like Pam. Take on a job. Come on.
好吧，吉姆已经到达潘的宿舍了。你注意到潘是宿舍管理员了吗？注意到了。她是宿管。这太完美了。这很完美，但也挺像潘的。承担工作。拜托。
Well, Jim tells the documentary crew, you know what, why don't you go check out Pam's art over there? And when they turn to look for it, he quickly shuts the door, right? And at 18 minutes 31 seconds, you hear the cameraman sigh. You hear Randall Einhorn sigh. Yes, that's Randall. And that was improvised. He just did that and they loved it and they kept it in.
好吧，吉姆对纪录片摄制组说，你知道吗，你们为什么不去看看潘那边的艺术作品呢？当他们转身去看时，他迅速关上了门，对吧？在18分31秒时，你能听到摄影师叹气。你能听到兰德尔·艾因霍恩叹气。是的，那是兰德尔。那是即兴发挥。他只是那样做了，而他们很喜欢并保留了下来。
Oh yeah, so fun. I would like to say, Pam, thank you for finally wearing a hoodie or any kind of casual clothing here at art school. I feel like she just has been overdressed since she got there. We are on two different pages on this. I think that Pam has looked amazing for art school. I love her ponytail. I just think, and this was a choice that I should say that this has all been a choice.
哦，是的，太有趣了。我想说，潘，谢谢你终于在艺术学校穿连帽衫或任何休闲服装了。我觉得自从她来到这里以来，她一直穿得过于正式了。在这个问题上我们俩意见不一致。我觉得潘在艺术学校看起来棒极了。我喜欢她的马尾辫。我只是觉得，这是一个选择，我应该说这一切都是一个选择。
It's on purpose. It's all to make her stand out a little bit, to be like she isn't dressing the way the young people dress today. Right. Okay. So like I'm giving her grief about it, but you guys, we planned this. Right. This is her affected speech, how she's like, top of the mountain Tillya, should we walk
这是故意的。这都是为了让她有点脱颖而出，就像她穿的衣服跟当今年轻人的穿衣风格不同。对。好吧。所以我虽然在拿这个取笑她，但伙计们，这是我们计划好的。没错。这就是她那做作的说话方式，她怎么说来着，山顶的蒂利亚，我们应该走到这边来吗？
over here? Perhaps we'll sit here. Let me cross my legs and my stockings. What are you talking about? That's how she talks. No, she does not. What are you doing? I'm just messing with you.
也许我们会坐在这里。让我交叉双腿和我的丝袜。你在说什么呢？她就是这么说话的。不，她才不。你在干什么？我只是在逗你玩。
I really got worried. I was like, what? I am messing with you. I don't know how long Jim and Pam got to hang out and smooch, but Pam got a knock on her door. There was some girl mad at another girl because someone took someone's soy milk and now Jim is in like the dorm room common area at 18 minutes 55 seconds. Yeah.
我刚才真的很担心。我想，什么？我是在逗你玩。我不知道吉姆和潘聚在一起亲热了多久，但潘的宿舍门被敲响了。有个女孩生另一个女孩的气，因为有人拿了别人的豆奶，现在吉姆在宿舍的公共区域，在18分55秒时。对。
He's watching a baseball game. Yes. And Jenna, you can very faintly hear some sort of baseball commentators like announcers, sports announcers. Yeah. Those were played by our very own producer, James O'Carrie and Eric Colgen. All right. See, I wondered, is that a real baseball game?
他在看棒球比赛。是的。珍娜，你能非常微弱地听到某种棒球评论员的声音，就像播音员、体育播音员。对。那些声音是由我们自己的制片人詹姆斯·奥凯里和埃里克·科尔根扮演的。好吧。你看，我纳闷，那是真的棒球比赛吗？
So it's obviously real baseball footage, but then we put our own commentators on it. That's right. Well, Jim and I have been in touch with James. He is fantastic. He was that guy that could like get you anything on set. If you needed it, James got it. And we had lots of questions for him and he answered them for this episode. He even had the shooting draft, James.
所以这显然是真的棒球画面，但然后我们把我们自己的评论员声音加进去了。没错。好吧，我和吉姆一直跟詹姆斯有联系。他太棒了。他就是那种能在片场给你搞到任何东西的人。如果你需要什么，詹姆斯都能弄到。而且我们有很多问题要问他，他在这集里回答了这些问题。他甚至有拍摄剧本，詹姆斯。
Thank you so much. I feel like we might have a James Apedia. Yeah. It couldn't come at a better time. Yeah. You know, because we don't have Kent Apedia anymore, James. James Cary, will you be our James Apedia? Did we talk about Stanley's birthday?
非常感谢。我觉得我们可能要有一个“詹姆斯全书”了。对。这来得正是时候。对。你知道的，因为我们不再有“肯特全书”了，詹姆斯。詹姆斯·卡瑞，你愿意成为我们的“詹姆斯全书”吗？我们讨论过斯坦利的生日了吗？
I mean, it looks a little sad. Everyone's standing around eating fruit. Ronnie wants to know if anyone wants to dance. By the way, my Dolly Parton fans, did you catch the song playing? Oh yeah. Here you come again. I love that song. I love that song too.
我的意思是，它看起来有点悲伤。每个人都站在周围吃水果。罗妮想知道是否有人想跳舞。顺便说一句，我的多莉·帕顿粉丝们，你们捕捉到播放的歌了吗？哦，对。你又来了。我喜欢那首歌。我也喜欢那首歌。
I went and listened to it after I watched the episode. It's not the song I would play at a birthday party. No. No. Probably not. But I love that song. People are going to sneak off from this party, and they're going to have some cake in the warehouse.
看完这集后我特意去听了。这不是我想在生日派对上放的歌。不。不。大概不会。但我很喜欢这首歌。人们要从这个派对上溜走，他们要去仓库里吃点蛋糕。
The warehouse is the sneak site, clearly. Clearly. And I mean, isn't Angela uncomfortable being in that room with all those other people, including her fiance? She doesn't have any guilt about it. I guess not. She has no problem sleeping at night. We've established that.
仓库显然是偷吃地点。显然。我的意思是，安吉拉跟所有那些人（包括她的未婚夫）待在那个房间里，难道不觉得尴尬吗？她对此没有任何内疚感。我想没有吧。她晚上睡觉没有任何问题。我们已经确认过了。
That's true. Stanley is in the room with the cake, but he's not even eating it. He said his tastes have changed. Now all he likes is baklava, which I thought was a really interesting thing to say because baklava is very, very, very sweet. Like if you've lost your sweet tooth, I mean, it's nutty. I love a baklava. I do too.
这倒也是。斯坦利在有蛋糕的房间里，但他甚至不吃。他说他的口味变了。现在他只喜欢果仁蜜饼，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的话题，因为果仁蜜饼非常非常甜。就像如果你失去了对甜食的喜爱，我的意思是，它里面全是坚果。我很喜欢果仁蜜饼。我也是。
It's dense though. It's a dense, sugary treat. I know. And I often eat too much of it, and I get a stomach ache because, you know, they give you a tiny piece, and I'll eat like five of them because they're just so good. Well, that's what happens with you. You're always like, Ang, look how cute it's so tiny. I know.
不过它很扎实。这是一道扎实又含糖的点心。我知道。我经常吃得太多，然后胃疼，你知道的，因为他们只给你一小块，而我会吃上五块，因为它们太好吃了。好吧，你就是这样。你总是说，“安吉，看它多可爱，这么小。”我知道。
And then you're like, Ang, I have a stomach ache. I know. Dwight, Holly, Michael, and Ronnie spy on the group. Dwight's like, they should not be in there. You know why he's saying that. And Michael says, we should have our own party. Let's all go play mini golf. Ronnie and Michael and Dwight and Holly, that foursome.
然后你就说，“安吉，我胃疼。”我知道。德怀特、霍莉、迈克尔和罗妮在暗中观察这群人。德怀特说，他们不应该在那里面。你知道他为什么这么说。迈克尔说，我们应该办我们自己的派对。咱们去打迷你高尔夫吧。罗妮、迈克尔、德怀特和霍莉，这四人组。
Oh, I wish that happened. Me too. Well, Holly can't go because she has a date tonight. Hmm. And then Michael has the sweetest talking head. He's like, Holly doesn't need any luck. Everyone who meets her instantly loves her. Yeah.
哦，我希望这能发生。我也是。好吧，霍莉不能去，因为她今晚有约会。嗯。然后迈克尔有了一段最甜蜜的面对镜头独白。他说，霍莉根本不需要什么运气。每个见到她的人都会立刻爱上她。对。
So cute. I want these two kids to get together. Angela, I have a question for you about the next scene, which is when Dwight busts in and he kicks over the cake. Yeah. I wasn't there. I'm at art school. What was it like to shoot that scene?
太可爱了。我希望这俩人能在一起。安吉拉，关于下一场戏我有一个问题要问你，也就是德怀特闯进来踢翻蛋糕的那场戏。对。我不在。我在艺术学校。拍摄那个场景是什么感觉？
Here's the thing. That room was like, I mean, Jenna, it was like six feet by six feet. It is really small and we were all in there. They tried to put chairs in so that we could sit, but not everyone could sit, obviously. We were pretty crammed in. I remember I couldn't look at Phyllis or I would laugh whenever she had her exchange with Michael. She would kind of, you know, start to break a little.
事情是这样的。那个房间就像是，我的意思是，珍娜，它大约有六英尺乘六英尺。它真的很小，我们都在里面。他们试图把椅子放进去，以便我们能坐下，但显然不是每个人都能坐。我们挤得满满当当的。我记得我不能看着菲利斯，否则每当她和迈克尔有对手戏时我就会笑场。她会有点，你知道的，开始有点破功。
And then rain kicked over that cake with such like force, it went flying. We all got cake on us and then they would have to clean it up. And we couldn't do it very many times because we were like, rain, do you have to kick it that hard? So pretty much I just remember being crammed in and trying not to laugh. Well, I thought that scene looked like it was a lot of fun to shoot. And I know, don't ask Rainn Wilson to kick something unless you really want it kicked. Yeah.
然后雷恩以极大的力量踢翻了那个蛋糕，蛋糕飞了出去。我们身上都沾满了蛋糕，然后他们不得不清理干净。我们不能拍太多次，因为我们当时想：雷恩，你非得踢得那么用力吗？所以我基本上只记得我们挤在一起，努力不笑场。好吧，我觉得那个场景看起来拍得非常有趣。而且我知道，千万别让雷恩·威尔森去踢什么东西，除非你真的想把它踢飞。对。
Unless you want it to go flying. Yeah. I don't think they anticipated that that much cake would travel because it was quite a clean up. Well, now it is week five of the weight loss competition. The Scranton branch is not doing very well. Holly tells us that corporate has now upped the prize to five vacation days, but things are breaking down between people.
除非你想让它飞起来。我觉得他们没有预料到会有那么多蛋糕飞溅出来，因为那真是一场大扫除。好吧，现在是减肥比赛的第五周。斯克兰顿分公司表现得不是很好。霍莉告诉我们公司现在把奖品提高到了五天带薪休假，但人们之间的关系正在破裂。
I mean, Kevin's in the kitchen. He's making himself a peanut butter bagel. Creed and Kelly are glaring at him. Oh, there's a deleted scene where Meredith and Kelly and Holly are working on the dry erase board. Yeah. And Kelly goes, I'm doing a blood type diet. And Meredith goes, who gives a f***?
我是说，凯文在厨房里。他在给自己做一个花生酱百吉饼。克里德和凯莉正怒视着他。哦，有一个被删减的片段，梅雷迪思、凯莉和霍莉在白板前工作。对。然后凯莉说，我在执行血型饮食法。梅雷迪思说，谁他妈在乎？
And Kelly goes, what'd you say, whore? And Holly goes, I got it. Hey. Hey. Hey. Oh my gosh. I mean, things are getting really intense. They're so intense that Kelly says in a talking head that she swallowed a tapeworm last night
然后凯莉说，你刚说什么，贱货？霍莉说，我知道了。嘿。嘿。嘿。哦天哪。我是说，事情变得非常紧张。它们是如此紧张，以至于凯莉在访谈中说她昨晚吞下了一条绦虫
that Creed gave her from Mexico. Kelly, why would you swallow a worm Creed gave you? I know. Creed says it wasn't a tapeworm. Angela, I'll have you know, I looked it up. Yeah. The tapeworm diet is a real thing. Oh, God.
那是克里德从墨西哥给她的。凯莉，你为什么要吞下克里德给你的虫子？我知道。克里德说那不是绦虫。安吉拉，我告诉你，我查过了。是的。绦虫减肥法是真实存在的。哦，天哪。
Really? Well, it's obviously illegal in the United States and it's totally dangerous. Where are they doing it? I don't know, but I guess you can buy pills that have a tapeworm egg inside of it. Don't do this. No. I read on Healthline that it doesn't even work because yes, it feeds off your body's nutrients, but it feeds off the good stuff too, right?
真的吗？嗯，这在美国显然是非法的，而且极其危险。他们在哪里做这件事？我不知道，但我想你可以买到里面有绦虫卵的药丸。千万别这么做。不。我在Healthline上看到它甚至不管用，因为它确实会吸取你身体的营养，但它也会吸取好东西，对吧？
It doesn't just eat your fat, everybody. It eats everything and you get really sick. You can get diarrhea, abdominal pain, nausea, fever, weakness. You can also get bacterial infections. You can get neurological issues. Most of these pills are a scam. Okay. They do not really have a tapeworm, but a woman in Iowa swallowed a real one and she
它不只是吃你的脂肪，各位。它什么都吃，而且你会病得很重。你可能会腹泻、腹痛、恶心、发烧、虚弱。你还可能感染细菌。你可能会得神经系统疾病。这些药丸大多是个骗局。好吧。它们实际上并没有绦虫，但爱荷华州的一个女人吞下了一条真的，她
got super sick and she had to confess to her doctor what she did. He had to report it to the State Department. It was a whole crazy thing. He didn't even know how to kill it. It was a whole thing. Guys, do not swallow a tapeworm on purpose. Our words I'm saying just in case anyone out there thought they should. You know, Jenna, I have a tapeworm story, but you know I'm going to save it for the
病得非常重，她不得不向医生坦白自己做了什么。医生不得不将其报告给州卫生部门。这整件事太疯狂了。他甚至不知道怎么杀死它。整件事就是这样。伙计们，千万不要故意吞下绦虫。这是我们的话，我说出来以防外面有人觉得自己该这么做。你知道，珍娜，我有一个关于绦虫的故事，但你知道我要把它留到
finale. When we are done with the whole run of the office, you will remember, I don't want to spoil it. There is a scene in the finale. I don't want to spoil it. You'll remember, Jenna. Ben and I traded tapeworm stories. I'm saving it for the finale.
大结局时讲。当我们完成了《办公室》的全剧播放后，你会想起来的，我不想剧透。大结局里有一个场景。我不想剧透。你会想起来的，珍娜。本和我交流了各自的绦虫故事。我把它留到大结局。尼
Guys, if you've ever had a reason to tune in to at least our finale episode of Office Ladies, you have it now. There is a real life Angelo Rain moment that happens behind the scenes of the finale. It involves a tapeworm. We'll get to it. Well, guys, that's weight loss part one. We will be back next week with weight loss part two, when Jim has a big surprise for Pam.
伙计们，如果你曾经有任何理由收听我们《办公室女士》的大结局，你现在有了。幕后发生了一个现实生活中的安吉拉·金斯利时刻。它与绦虫有关。我们会讲到的。好吧，伙计们，这就是减肥（上）。我们下周将带着减肥（下）回归，届时吉姆会给帕姆一个巨大的惊喜。
We're going to tell you all about it. Aw, jam fans, you don't want to miss it. See you then. See ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
我们会把一切都告诉你。哦，Jam粉们，你们千万不要错过。到时候见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用StitcherPremium一个月，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。